Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Gleich am Start.
Musik
So.
Ja, das ist richtig,
der F-Programmer. Ich muss mir gerade was zu trinken
holen.
Excellent.
Moin.
So, jetzt bin ich am Start.
Ne, keine Krustentiere jetzt.
Auf dem Klo war ich schon.
Kann aber sein, dass man, so weiß man ja nie.
Das kündigt sich ja nicht drei Stunden im Vorfeld an.
Vielleicht muss ich während des Streams nochmal das, werden wir dann sehen.
Aber es gibt Schlimmeres.
Vor allem gibt es bestimmt auch Spannenderes, als was es zu diskutieren gibt.
Ich weiß noch nicht, wie lang.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich am besten anfangen soll
zu erzählen.
Ich hab doch aus Spaß
letztens, was heißt aus Spaß? Das war schon ernst
gemeint. Letztens gesagt,
wir können mal einen Stream machen,
wo ich mir die letzten
15 neuen
C++ Features angucke
und mich darüber ein bisschen
aufrege.
so als, wie gesagt,
ich will ja der größte C++ Hater
überhaupt werden. Da muss man üben.
Und dann hab ich mir gedacht,
das wär doch viel lustiger,
wenn wir so einen Stream machen,
mit
Herzfrequenz dabei.
So, der Chat hat auch gesagt,
ja, das ist eine viel bessere Idee.
Kann man gleich mal sehen,
wie sehr welches C++ Feature mich mehr aufregt.
Das Problem ist nur, ich habe nichts gefunden,
wie ich meine Herzfrequenz gescheit darstellen kann in OBS,
beziehungsweise überhaupt gescheit abrufen kann.
Du findest jede Menge Zeug im Internet.
Gibt es sogar fertige Gadgets, die du über einen Browser mit Web-USB und sowas
aufmachen kannst.
Aber die sind alle für Bluetooth.
Und
meine Uhr,
die sendet die Herzfrequenz nur
über Ant+.
Ant ist so ein Low Energy
Wireless Protokoll von Garmin.
Und
ich habe so ein paar kleine Projekte gefunden,
aber nichts, was irgendwie so aussah,
als dass man das gescheit benutzen kann.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Es ist ja nicht für die Garmin-Uhr.
es ist ja für für desktop oder für linux oder wie man es wie man es nimmt am besten natürlich
in go dass das ganze cross platform ist und dann mit und dann mit halt eine embedded webseite die
das anzeigt man muss erstmal gucken wie man das auslässt so und also wie gesagt bluetooth easy
da gibt es da gibt es 3000 sachen ganz wenn du wenn du nach heartbeat sensor suchst gibt es da
gibt es komplett fertige hier hart beat sensor widgets da gibt es komplett hier so was hier
komplett fertige dinge da kannst du dir sagen das meine ich gar nicht irgendwie sowas heart rate
widgets tag widgets hier da kannst du hier gucken kannst du kannst die ganzen krabbel anzeigen das
ding ist diese teile hier haben was ich dachte dass da zum beispiel ja dass das will ich haben
Die Dinger, die funktionieren nur mit, also keine Ahnung, ob es auf der Seite jetzt so ist, ja, aber keine Ahnung, wie man es auf der Seite macht.
Zumindest, die Dinger funktionieren oftmals halt über Bluetooth.
Man kann ja mittlerweile USB über einen Browser machen.
und ich habe einen.
Ich habe einen.
Ich habe einen Herzfrequenzgurt,
der kann Endplus und Bluetooth senden,
aber Herzfrequenzgurt ist mir zu unbequem,
hier drei Stunden zu hocken mit Herzfrequenzgurt.
So, ich habe aber für Swift,
habe ich einen Endplus-Stick.
Sowohl mein Smart-Trainer,
als auch mein Herzfrequenzsensor
verbindet sich über Endplus.
hier zu Zwift, zu Zwift, Zwift.
Das heißt, das geht potenziell.
Wir müssen jetzt bloß noch gucken, wie.
Also man kann das auslesen.
Ich habe gestern ein bisschen rumgeguckt.
Ich habe, den Dude wollte ich jetzt nicht.
Ich habe auch mal hier KI gefragt
und ein bisschen rumgeschaut,
was es für Möglichkeiten gibt.
Also ich habe einiges gefunden.
So richtig fertig,
fertig, komplett
ausgebaut.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht so
richtig, ja.
Also wir müssen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
basteln, ne Quatsch, nicht vor Ems.
Wir müssen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen basteln und gucken,
wie kriegen wir den Herzfrequenzsensor
überhaupt ausgelesen.
Ich habe mehrere Projekte gefunden.
Was mich ja
persönlich angesprochen hat,
ist das hier, also auf den ersten Blick.
Was mich auf den ersten Blick
angesprochen hat, ist das hier.
Von Steven.
Eine
Nplus Class Library.
Und das ist in
.NET.
Wir haben schon lange nichts mehr in .NET gemacht.
Aber da habe ich mir mal die Examples angeguckt.
Und da bin ich irgendwie
zu dem Schluss gekommen,
das scheint Windows-only zu sein.
Oder?
Ich weiß nicht, woher das ist.
Also das scheint Windows-only zu sein.
Das ist die offizielle...
Guck, das ist die offizielle N+.
Das ist Windows-only.
Also leider funzt das nicht.
Und auch wie das mit dem USB-Stick funktioniert,
war hier ein bisschen
ein bisschen wir.
Das nächste, was ich gefunden habe,
ist dieses Projekt hier.
Ich zeige das mal.
Das nächste, was ich gefunden habe, ist dieses Projekt.
Moin.
Das ist schon ein bisschen outdated, overrated,
cheapated.
Aber
das hat zumindest
alles drin.
Also es sieht auf den ersten Blick so aus,
als hat das alles drin, was man braucht.
Also man kann ein USB-Device
öffnen.
Und dann hat Bitsensor irgendwie drauf zugreifen sollen. Ich habe auch hier ein Beispiel gefunden. Der Typ ruft quasi Pedaldrehtfrequenz ab und Power-Up von seinem Fahrrad. Das geht auch.
Ja, aber so wirklich geil sah das alles nicht aus.
Dann habe ich noch diese Library hier gefunden.
Die wohl relativ beliebt ist.
Das ist eine Python Library.
Da habe ich aber gar nicht so richtig durchgeblickt.
Ja, also das geht wohl auch irgendwie.
Also das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Was ich jetzt nicht ganz checke ist, wie dieses Ding, ob das das hier eingebaut hat oder nicht.
Also ich habe den Stick hier.
Also das sind die Sachen, die wir mal ausprobieren können.
Was mich ja persönlich noch reizen würde ist...
Also ich finde das hier, das habe ich zwar nicht ganz gecheckt, aber ich finde das sieht noch am vielversprechendsten aus.
von diesen, ich mach mal diese drei
diese drei Dinger auf
ups, das wollte ich jetzt gar nicht drücken
aber was mich ja persönlich
reizen würde ist
das einfach
from scratch zu machen
weil so schwer kann es ja nicht sein
ein USB
Stick, naja was heißt so schwer
kann es ja nicht sein
ein USB Stick
anzusprechen unter Linux
und da irgendwelche Werte von auszulesen
Also, der Flow ist ja dann so, meine Uhr am Handgelenk broadcastet per N+, meine Herzfrequenz, und ich habe hier den USB-Stick.
Famous last words, ja.
Und ich habe hier einen USB-Stick, der empfängt das.
Und da dachte ich halt, okay
So kompliziert
Kannst du mal erklären, was N plus ist?
Was soll N plus sein?
End plus, nicht N plus
End, so schreibt man das, guck
End plus
End, so wie Ameise
End plus ist ein
Ja, ich würde
Ich würde tatsächlich
Eine Stufe oben drüber ansetzen
Mit irgendeiner Library, die das für mich macht
Nplus ist ein
Low Energy
Low Power Wireless Protokoll
von Garmin
allerdings ist Garmin mittlerweile
nicht mehr der einzige Hersteller
der das benutzt
also Swift kann das benutzen
für Kommunikation mit Uhren
und Smart Trainern
mein Wahoo Smart Trainer
fürs Fahrrad unterstützt das auch
aber ich würde mal sagen
die bessere Wahl ist
für solche Sachen auf jeden Fall Bluetooth.
Ja.
Die beste
Variante wäre tatsächlich Bluetooth, aber
meine Uhr kann nicht
über Bluetooth die
Herzfrequenz broadcasten.
Ich hab einen Herzfrequenzgurt,
der kann das, aber das finde ich zu unbequem.
Also die nächste Uhr kann das vielleicht, ich kann ja
gerade mal kurz gucken,
ob die neuen Forerunner das können.
erstmal wenn man schon gerade dabei sind lass mal gucken erweitert premium essentiell ja
bla das ist okay dass die kleine an ok kann die technische daten lieferumfang end
Konnektivität, Bluetooth und
Endplus. Ist halt
die Frage, ob das auch gilt
für Broadcast
Herzfrequenz.
Wir können
ja einfach mal ganz frech,
das wird halt eine KI nicht wirklich wissen, aber wir fragen mal,
kann die
den Hardbeat
per Bluetooth
Broadcasten?
Wie laufen die Storchs?
Ganz gut
Nein, Alter
Chat-GPT ist so dumm
Dies ist so dumm, Alter
Wisst ihr, Chat-GPT ist so useless
mittlerweile geworden
Guck mal, kann die vorhin per Bluetooth
broadcasten? Ja
Die Vor- und Vorherkann-Herzfrequenz
broadcasten
Die Uhr scheint
nicht über Bluetooth
WTF, Chat-GPT, laber halt
kein Bullshit.
Okay, vergleichen. Wir können das ja heute,
ich hab mich mal eingeloggt, wir können das mal
heute mit anderen KIs vergleichen, okay?
Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab
einen Mammoth
Account, ja. Die E-Mail-Adresse ist
by the way nicht geheim, die steht bei mir im Twitch-Profil.
Das ist da, wo man Business-Inquiries
hinschicken kann, also nicht, dass ihr jetzt denkt,
liegt. So, wir können ja mal,
was wollen wir fragen?
Wollen wir mal, wir
gehen mal ein bisschen aus, wir fragen mal Claude, okay?
Oh, ich bin mir nicht
Websuche, okay.
Okay, Claude
fabriziert es, es reimt
sich irgendwas zusammen.
Ist das wirklich so?
Schau mal im Handbuch nach, ob das echt so ist.
Okay, das ist zu dumm.
PDF, okay.
Soll ich das Handbuch jetzt noch suchen für die oder was?
Na gut
Okay
Forerunner Handbuch
Zubehör
Wo steht denn sowas hier?
Handbücher
Benutzerhandbuch
Ja
Hier ist das Handbuch
Alter bist du dumm?
Okay, da ist es drum
Ist Cloud zur Zeit die beste AI?
Das kommt immer ein bisschen
Also, ich würde nicht so weit gehen
Sagen, das ist die beste
Also, für Programmieraufgaben
Würde ich sagen, ist
Opus 5
Heißt das überhaupt noch Opus?
Wahrscheinlich das unkomplizierteste
Ja, aber es kommt immer ein bisschen
Auf den Anwendungszweck an
naja,
also du hast mit Claude
selber schon mehr
Möglichkeiten.
Du hast mit Claude
schon mehr Möglichkeiten, was
Agent Coding und sowas
angeht und ordentlichen Command Line Client, alles.
Das Schöne bei Mammut ist,
dass
du
Zugriff auf alle
Models hast, die es so gibt.
Du kannst hier, ich kann dir sagen, prompt
hier, Kekkel. Und du hast
Zugriff auf alle Models und
Untermodels davon. Das heißt, du kannst auch
welche verwenden, die nicht
so viel
kosten.
Ja. Seine
Limits kann man hier angucken. Und der Vorteil
ist, Mammoth kostet nur, die Basic,
das Basic-Abo,
kostet nur 10 Euro im Monat
versus, glaube ich, 20 Euro, wo es bei
Claude losgeht. Aber du hast
halt auch, jetzt auch nicht riesen Limits
oder so.
Also wenn du da irgendwie drei Tage irgendwelche Agents laufen lässt oder so, dann bist du total schnell am Limit.
Aber du kannst zum Beispiel auch sagen, wir wollen GPT, aber wir wollen hier GPT, keine Ahnung, was ich soll.
Could you clarify what you mean with Kekkel?
Twitch Emote.
Guck, der Chat-GPT weiß Bescheid.
Also, Claude ist zu dumm in dem Fall.
Das könnte aber auch an der Websuche liegen, die zu blöde ist dafür.
Wollen wir mal checken, ob Chat-GPT das checkt?
Schau mal hier im Handbuch nach, ob die das kann.
Bam.
Ja, ich habe genau das von dir verlinkte Game im Handbuch geprüft.
ein Classic.
Tja.
Es ist einfach dumm.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es funktioniert.
Ganz ehrlich.
Wenn du möchtest, kann ich als nächstes gezielt
in den Garmin... Ja, mach.
Okay, okay.
Die aktuelle Garmin-Support-Seite ist hier aber eindeutig.
Er nennt die Formel explizit unter
Devices that broadcast hard-read via Bluetooth.
Glauben wir das, ChatGPT?
Glauben wir denen das?
Okay.
Devices that broadcast via Bluetooth.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Äh, ich hab ne...
Ich hab ne
Forerunner 255.
Und die broadcasten mich
mit Bluetooth.
Das lügt.
das liegt einfach so ständig die gameliste ständig
du musst es einstellen meint so dass es eine extra settings okay vielleicht ist
das ganze chat wo habe ich wo habe ich meine uhr
das muss jetzt mal gucken das ganze problem gar kein problem
Okay, wartet mal.
Vielleicht ist das gar kein Problem.
Broadcasting.
Broadcasting Hardrate Data to Garmin Devices.
Ja, ja.
Aber das...
Das ist nur N+.
Das ist nicht Bluetooth.
Also wie soll das funktionieren?
Das ist...
Das ist nicht...
Das ist N+.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, die...
Ich glaube, die Liste hier ist Blödsinn, weil...
Ich gehe nochmal in die Settings, okay?
Ob da irgendwas in der Richtung drin steht.
Wo könnte das stehen?
History, Activity,
Sensors and Accessories.
Hä?
Nee.
Connectivity.
Phone, Garmin, Share.
Was? Phone? Nee.
Also ich bin mir relativ sicher,
die Uhr kann das nicht.
System.
Language, Passcode, Time, Display, Satellite, Sound.
Ne.
Ich kann ja mal ein Software-Update machen.
Also sogar Auto-Update an.
Das kann das Super-Endlos.
Also ich behaupte, Garmin weiß selber nicht, was sie hier schreiben.
Also ich habe der Uhr jetzt gesagt, sie soll ein Firmware-Update machen.
Vielleicht ist es ja mit dem neuesten Firmware-Update drin.
Also wie gesagt
Garmin
Forerunner
Broadcast
Heart
Rate
Bluetooth
Das kann die nicht
Ich hab gestern danach geguckt
Ja, das ist halt Blödsinn
Ja gut
Okay, vielleicht meinen die das so
Du kannst die Uhr verbinden
mit der Garmin App
über Bluetooth.
Das funktioniert.
Aber das bringt mir auf dem Desktop
nichts. Die Garmin App
habe ich ja nur auf dem...
Ach, warte mal.
Gibt es eine ordentliche Garmin App?
Garmin App
Windows für
Garmin Connect?
Ja, das ist aber...
Irgendein Mist, oder?
Einfache Karten- und Software-Updates.
Synchronisierung.
Ja, nee, nee, nee.
Hast du gesehen, was ich gelinkt habe?
Nee.
Ich habe zu viele Fenster auf.
Äh.
Okay.
Was denn?
Wo denn?
was haben wir hier
repo with and plus projects das bestimmt weib kohle
das bin ich was bin ich hier sehen and sdk linux and dll and cpp monka w
Ey, hör mal bloß auf.
C++ wollen wir jetzt nicht.
Also, kann Garmin Express...
Wir müssen uns mal kurz angucken.
Kann Garmin Express live Herzfrequenz?
Schauen wir uns mal Images davon an.
Nö.
Kann's nicht.
Das ist so eine uralte Drecksoftware.
Kann es nicht.
Garmin Software
to show
hard beat
Bluetooth Windows.
Das gibt es nicht. Ich habe gestern extra
geguckt.
Broadcast to Apps.
Ja klar, mit einem Endplastik.
Das ist aber halt
nicht das, was ich machen will.
Bluetooth Broadcasting.
Podcasting.
Virtual Run Profile.
Okay.
Moment.
Ich habe ja eine 255, die ist noch neuer.
How it works.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hier steht ja was.
hier steht ja was hauen works firma habe ich die aktuellste was habe ich für eine
firma ich guck was für eine firma version habe jetzt mal kurz checken wo
sieht man das system
software version 28 05
software version 28 05 gut sind schon 28
So und jetzt
Virtual Run
Virtual Run, okay
Und jetzt, so after you get a beta
Ah, vielleicht ist es nur beta
Then the watch will show you a note
About adding a new sport
In this case
The virtual run sport
You need to go into settings
Menu and edit
Okay, was muss ich machen?
Go to Activities
Okay, das mache ich jetzt
Vielleicht ist das Problem ja viel einfacher
Zu lösen als gedacht
Go to Activities
Okay
Add
Und jetzt was?
Virtual Run
Ja, unter
unter
unter welchem
unter welcher Kategorie
ist das denn jetzt?
Running.
Virtual Run. Hab ich. Hab ich.
Nicht als Favoriten setzen.
Okay.
Okay. Virtual Run.
Hab ich.
zack
next und jetzt habe ich virtual run
virtual run
use this activity
to connect your watch to
other virtual training
applications
okay
das geht
ich fass es nicht
äh Moment
wie Bluetooth ich hab doch
ich hab doch letztens
habe ich doch so eine App gefunden.
Warte mal.
Ich habe doch letztens eine App gefunden.
Web,
Bluetooth,
Heartbeat.
Das da, ha?
Genau. Connect Device.
Okay, turn on Bluetooth.
Bluetooth.
Wo? Moment.
Bluetooth?
Okay.
Ah, es ist Connect Device.
Der findet nix.
Yes.
Ready to pair, sagt er.
Ready to pair.
Da tut sich aber nix.
Also der...
Ha! Forerunner!
Warum sollte ich mich leaken?
Inwiefern?
Als laufen die Leute durch die Stadt und scannen meine Uhren, Alter.
Bluetooth-Mac-Leak.
OMG, Alter.
Okay.
Und jetzt, boah, jetzt zieh ich die Uhr mal an.
Wie jetzt?
Warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr?
Was jetzt?
Connect device.
Eben war es doch noch da.
Jetzt wieder ready to pair.
Das ist ich nicht so ganz sicher
Ob es funktioniert oder nicht
So wirklich stable ist es nicht, oder?
Forerunner, das ist es doch
Ja.
Macht das jetzt was?
Ich lege die mal hinten an meinen Rechner, das Ding.
Nee, das ist zu dumm.
Das ist zu dumm.
Ist das Onboard-Bluetooth?
Ist das?
Das Pairing habe ich schon bestätigt.
Der sagt die ganze Zeit weiter, ready to pair.
Und es ist ja auch paired angeblich.
Okay, wartet mal.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Lass mich mal kurz hinten an den Rechner.
Chat geht es... Ich bin dumm.
Ich benutze das Bluetooth am Rechner normalerweise nicht.
Ich habe alle Antennen abgeschraubt.
Könnte es daran liegen, dass es nicht geht?
Vielleicht.
Das wäre möglich.
Habe ich denn...
Wo habe ich denn diese Kack-Antennen?
Habe ich hier überhaupt noch Antennen irgendwo, Alter?
Sind hier Antennen drinne irgendwo?
Antennen?
Hier ist eine Antenne.
Ha!
gefunden okay ich gehe mal kurz ein rechner
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
das passt nicht aber ich wüsste nicht welche antenne sonst sein sollte die
liegt nämlich hinten neben also hier vorne neben rechner das muss sie doch
sein ich gehe mal an meine ich habe noch mehr ich habe noch mehr antenne ich gehe
mal kurz in die schublade
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe hier noch zwei.
Ich habe hier noch zwei. Mal gucken, ob die passt.
Hä?
Wasser.
So, ich habe keine Ahnung, welche...
Okay, jetzt ist er auch noch runtergefallen.
So.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, welche Antenne
hinten an meinen Rechner
dran passt. Also ich habe
jetzt drei Stück ausprobiert und alle
passen nicht.
Das ist schon ziemlich kacke.
Habe ich denn noch hier irgendwas liegen,
was nach Antenne aussieht, was von meinem Rechner
sein könnte?
Nee, ne?
Das ist nix.
Nix.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Ich muss die Dinger doch irgendwo haben.
Hm.
Wo könnte ich die Antenne für meinen Rechner haben?
Bluetooth-Zeug.
Das ist doch irgendein Standard-Krempel, oder?
Im Gehäuse.
Nee, Quatsch.
Im Gehäuse ist da nix.
Nee, nee.
Ich muss das hier irgendwo liegen haben, aber ich seh's nicht.
Ich find's nicht.
Hä?
Okay, was?
Da können wir doch bestimmt irgendeine Antenne zweckentfremden, oder?
Ich geh noch mal kurz an den Schrank.
Ich hab, ich hab ja...
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So, ich habe jetzt noch drei andere Antennen.
Wenn die nicht gehen, hab ich keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Vielen Dank.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Ich hab nicht die richtige Antenne da
für mein Bluetooth-Teuch.
Ich hab das seit drei Jahren, wo ich den Rechner nicht gebraucht hab,
weil ich brauche
eine Antenne, die ein Loch hat
und nicht diesen Stift.
Das ist das Falsche.
Ich frag mich, wo ich das hab.
Weil ich hatte da schon mal Antennen dran.
Das weiß ich.
Das kann doch nicht so weit weg sein.
Also erst einmal richtig hängen geblieben,
da ich die überhaupt abgemacht habe.
Das ist schon ziemlich dämlich.
Aha.
Aber hier ist sonst nichts
drin.
Mini-PC.
Ah, sehr gute Idee.
Wir können das mit dem Mini-PC probieren.
Geht denn WebUSB, geht das auf Linux mittlerweile?
Gescheit.
Mini-PC.
Ja, geht.
Okay, dann machen wir es mit dem Mini-PC.
Dann machen wir Bluetooth.
Machen wir Bluetooth wieder aus.
Zack.
Mini-PC an.
Siehst du mal hier.
Wieder Abenteuer.
Zwar nicht wirklich das, was ich machen wollte,
aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich nichts selbst programmieren muss,
soll mir das durchaus recht sein.
Ich muss den Kram
ja hier irgendwo haben.
Also weit weg können die Antennen
ja letztendlich nicht sein.
Wahrscheinlich liegt es irgendwo hier auf dem Schreibtisch
noch in irgendeiner Ecke und ich sehe es einfach nicht.
Ich habe jetzt gerade aber hier schon mal
alles ein bisschen...
Durchgewühlt?
Da ist nix.
Also hier auf dem Schreibtisch ist nix.
Jetzt mal kurz Deskflow starten.
Logitech-Treiber starten.
Das Schreibtisch?
Mein Schreibtisch sieht ungefähr so aus,
wie mein...
wie meine Tab-Bar.
So, hat das Ding Bluetooth hier?
Neofetch.
Sieht man das?
Wo sieht man das?
Check.
Check if Linux has Bluetooth.
Okay.
Beste.
LS-USB oder irgendwie sowas?
Ja, da wäre ich jetzt auch drauf gekommen.
Ich dachte, es gibt da was besseres für.
Bluetooth.
Okay, wir haben Bluetooth am Start.
Exquisite.
Okay, also.
Web-USB.
Web-USB geht aber nur in Chrome.
Firefox kann das nicht.
Chrome.
Okay, so.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir nochmal kurz
Hier auf diese Seite gehen
Wo hatten wir
Hier die da brauchen wir
Ah heute geht
Copy Paste wieder nicht
Web Bluetooth
Heartbeat
Okay
Reject
Connect Device
Web Bluetooth is not supported by your browser
Okay, das ist ja auch Chromium
Muss ich das echte
Den Main Character, muss ich den installieren, ja
Google Chrome
Oder, warte mal
Chromium Web USB
Moment, ne, ne, ne
Nicht Web USB
Web Bluetooth
Activate
Okay
Anscheinend muss man das
vorher noch enablen.
Bluetooth. Web Bluetooth?
Default.
Äh.
Enable?
Okay.
Relaunch.
Geht das jetzt?
Connect device. Aha.
Wie, hab ich doch.
Turn on Bluetooth
Okay
Könnte es sein, dass man dafür
Root-Rechte braucht?
Was gibt es denn sonst noch hier bei Bluetooth?
Systray, welcher Systray?
Ich habe kein Systray
Oh doch, hab ich
Keck weh
Ich hab nix gesagt
Okay
Forerunner
Ha
Lüg überhaupt nicht.
Lüg nicht.
Ich hab die Uhr nicht mal an.
Das lügt komplett.
Okay, mal gucken, ob die überhaupt was...
Ich zieh die jetzt mal an.
Ich zieh die jetzt mal an, okay?
Okay.
jetzt habe ich 73, 74, 75.
Ich war heute Morgen
ja schon
42 Minuten
rennen. Da ist die nächsten paar Stunden immer ein bisschen
höher, aber...
Okay.
Jetzt ist es ein bisschen runtergegangen wieder.
Gut.
Aber das ist ja easy.
Das geht ja einfach jetzt.
Copy URL for OBS.
Ja gut, ähm...
Das ist jetzt keine allzu schlaue Idee, das jetzt zu leaken, aber egal.
Ihr seht's ja eh.
Eigentlich eine coole Sache, oder?
6-7-Hardrate.
Hardrate-Leak.
So, jetzt müssen wir das Ganze noch in OBS einbinden.
Aber Chat, wir gucken trotzdem nachher,
wie man das per N-Plus auslesen kann, oder?
Weil, also ich meine,
Wir haben jetzt immerhin schon mal einen guten Workaround.
No.
Trägst du beim Laufen eine Brustgurt?
Nee. Aber die sind nicht schlecht, die Uhren.
Du hast da
plus, minus, 1, 2%
Unterschied, aber das macht's
nicht fett.
Der N-Plus-Champ.
Okay, also lass jetzt mal hier
QN
Wo muss ich da für hin?
Ich muss jetzt mal hier rüber, kurz
Ähm
Was für eine URL brauchen wir hier?
App?
Wie geht das?
Hyperrate
.io
Slash
Ich kann in die andere Richtung
In die andere
Hubszeug. In die andere Richtung nicht copy-pasten.
Animate.
Animation.
Slash.
79.
Slash. Und dann
QN4FF.
OR.
Okay, nice.
So.
69.
So, und jetzt?
Add Source.
Browser.
Heartbeat.
Ja, ja.
Ich mach das vielleicht mal ein bisschen weiter runter hier.
Mal was sieht.
Source.
Und jetzt?
Da ist es!
Wartet mal.
Wie konnte man das jetzt schneiden?
So, ne?
Okay, Chat.
Ich würde sagen...
Ready?
Ready für C++-Stream, hä?
Live IQ
overlay.
Ah, der ist ziemlich low heute, glaube ich.
Okay, wir müssen noch mal kurz checken.
Wir müssen noch mal kurz checken, ob das auch so richtig funktioniert.
Chat.
Was ist eine gute Übung, wo ich nicht viel rum, wo ich das Headset aufbehalten kann, wo der Puls ein bisschen hoch geht?
Liegestützen oder...
Na, Liegestützen mit der Uhr am Handgelenk ist nicht so geil.
Luft anhalten?
Kniebeugen.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, Knieboy.
Fappen, Alter, der Chat wieder.
Okay, da muss ich erst nochmal den Gummi von meiner Hose ein bisschen enger machen.
Das rutscht die beim Knieboyen machen.
Okay, lass mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert hier.
Warum geht das jetzt runter? Sollte es nicht hochgehen?
Ah, jetzt. Okay.
Ich bin hier schon bei 1,80.
Ja, okay, es geht auch hoch.
Okay, ein bisschen schneller.
Dass der Puls noch ein bisschen rauf geht.
Morgen KS.
Es geht voll auf die Knie.
Ich habe einen Puls von 2,90
laut meiner Uhr. Warum stimmt die Anzeige hier nicht?
Okay, jetzt geht es rauf.
Beim Luftanhalten geht das runter.
Ich will nicht, dass es runter geht.
Ich will, dass es rauf geht.
ich habe eine garmin forerunner 255s v2 max um die 46 ich bin ich bin 42 jahre alt
80 kilo schwer 1,75 groß ok scheiße funktionieren kann ich auf der stelle
ein bisschen rennen oder so. Bringt das vielleicht
auch was?
Ja, auf der Stelle rennen ist viel besser
als Kniebeugen.
Ach, wo es rutscht.
Jetzt haben wir 100.
25.
Okay, es funktioniert.
Es funzt.
Genug.
crazy wie schnell der puls wo ich bewegte hoch ist normal und das
hat der sinn und zweck der sache post ja mehr sauerstoff überall
mal schauen bis dauert bis wieder normal ist achtet relativ schnell
Musik
Oh, jetzt wird er normal.
Äh, ach ja, war ein bisschen abgeschnitten.
Okay, das liegt an meinen dummen OBS-Settings.
Jetzt haben wir hier auch...
Okay, jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz checken.
Jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz auf der Stelle rennen.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob der Puls jetzt nicht abgeschnitten ist.
Warte mal.
Lasst gucken.
Jetzt müsste es langsam aber wieder hochgehen.
So, jetzt passt es.
Jetzt ist es gut.
Jetzt passt's
Excellent
Also Chat
Das ursprüngliche Problem haben wir in der Tat relativ easy gefixt
Das wusste ich nicht, dass es so ein
Virtual Running
Gibt
Wenn ich jetzt hier rausgehe
Bricht dann der Puls
Ah, jetzt bricht es ab
Okay, guck jetzt, jetzt ist es nicht mal gepaert
Jetzt ist es nicht mehr gepaart. Das sieht man wahrscheinlich auch hier.
Die Frage ist, geht es jetzt automatisch wieder an, wenn ich dieses Virtual Running wieder anmache?
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt anfängt, sich erneut zu paaren.
Also ich habe jetzt einen Puls von 72.
Anscheinend nicht.
muss man es vielleicht restarten.
Okay, so richtig geil ist das natürlich nicht.
Aber die ID bleibt gleich, ne?
Die ID bleibt gleich.
Ja, das ist okay.
Wenn die ID gleich bleibt,
dann kann man wenigstens immer,
ohne dass man das ja austauschen muss.
Das ist okay.
Okay, okay.
Ah, ja.
Das ist doch vollkommen fein.
Okay.
Dann machen wir das mal wieder aus.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriegen wir das per
Endplus selbst
abgefragt, ne?
Also Web,
Bluetooth und so, Funst, alles kein
Problem. Das heißt, jetzt machen wir
Bluetooth wieder aus.
Max, schau, wie viele Leute Montagmittags...
Naja, es ist die Hälfte von dem, was Sonntagstream staut.
Ist schon ein Unterschied.
Okay, ich gebe auch zu, das Thema ist jetzt gerade vielleicht ein bisschen wir.
Max rennt vom Rechner rum und...
Oh ja, erstmal...
Wir haben gestern geupdatet, da kann es schon mal über einen Gig neue Updates geben.
Aber wir probieren das jetzt mal aus.
Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus.
Also, Chat, was...
Also, wir rufen das jetzt...
ähm...
mit... mit Endplus...
gucken wir, dass wir das jetzt...
USB...
dass wir das jetzt selbst abrufen können.
Guck mal, ich hab hier LsUSB.
da habe ich ein...
Äh...
Sieht man das nicht hier irgendwie?
Achso! Ah, bin ich dumm.
Ich hab den Stick hier am anderen Rechner dran.
Moment, ich mach den mal hier dran.
Oh, hier.
Es bin connected, Leute!
Und jetzt? Was kann man machen, wenn man da oben drauf klickt?
Okay, was auch immer.
Jetzt schauen wir mal.
Ja, guck hier.
Hier ist er.
Dynastream Innovations.
TTY USB 0.
Was ist denn der
Suunto Converter?
Was?
And plus USB-Stick not pairing.
Ah, das heißt, ich hab jetzt...
Moment, heißt das, ich hab jetzt hier ein Device oder was?
Ähm...
Dev, TTY, USB, 0?
Gibt das irgendwas aus?
Also ich glaube so einfach
Ich glaube so einfach öffnen
Geht dann doch nicht
Warte mal ich mach mal Broadcast
Broadcast
Herzfrequenz mach ich mal an
Also die N Plus Herzfrequenz
Da kommt aber nix, ne?
Da kommt nix
Ist sicher, dass er das richtig erkennt?
Ich meine, was zum Teufel ist denn
bitteschön der Suunto-Konverter?
Linux?
Wenn ihr Plugin...
Ah, guck mal!
The Linux kernel's generic USB serial driver
has mistakenly claimed your N-Plus device.
Ist das schlecht?
Wüsstest du dich nicht mit sowas wie Screen...
Keine Ahnung.
Aber guck dir mal.
Wenn ich da ein Device habe,
ja,
da könnte ich doch theoretisch
von dort direkt raw
das auslesen. Okay, wisst ihr was?
Jetzt, wir lassen...
Fuck, ich kann jetzt nicht richtig copy-pasten.
Das sagt ja mal
Hardcore.
Ich bin hier
eingeloggt, KI-mäßig.
Ich bin hier KI-mäßig eingeloggt,
aber ich kann nicht raus-Copy-Pasten.
Das ist halt richtig stumm.
Okay.
Da müssen wir per SSH da drauf,
dass wir Copy-Pasten können.
Mir fällt nichts Besseres ein.
SSHD.
Windows hat doch mittlerweile
PowerShell.
Windows hat doch mittlerweile SSH eingebaut, oder?
Ja.
Max, add.
Yes.
Okay, Funst.
Oh, guck mal, das Windows Terminal kann sogar meine Shell und Color Highlighting und sowas machen.
Das hätte ich jetzt aber nicht gedacht.
Hättet ihr das gedacht?
Also das wird schon...
Special.
Read.
Hard beat from USB-Stick.
Lord.
Nicht so nett.
Mammut.
Was machst du da?
Ah.
You have two main approaches.
Das ist jetzt
Sonnet. Ich will das...
Das Denkmodell...
Wie kann ich das jetzt umstellen, gescheit,
auf Opus, dass da das...
Opus.
Denkmodelle.
Ja, wir
reprompten jetzt mit dem Denkmodell.
Also, was will er?
Bla bla bla.
That means you talk to it plain serial port.
Okay.
Ah, da müsste ich wirklich mit Minicom oder sowas drauf.
Pip install openend.
Aha.
Open and scan.
Okay, so einfach ist das.
Glauben wir das?
Glauben wir das, Opus, was er hier sagt?
Raw Serial. No unbinding needed.
Oh ja.
Viel geiler hier.
Magic.
Einfach Magic...
Magic Bites.
So mag ich das.
Da weißt du Bescheid, Alter.
Oh, ich brauche
Write Access da drauf. Habe ich überhaupt
Write Access da drauf?
Dev, TTY, USB.
Nope.
Habe ich nicht.
Aber
wenn ich in die Gruppe
meinen User adde,
UUCP, was ist das eigentlich für ein
komischer User.
Unix to Unix Copy.
Okay, whatever.
Wenn ich in die Gruppe gehe,
UUCP,
bin ich denn
in der Gruppe UUCP?
Nee, ne?
Bin ich nicht.
Komm in die Gruppe, ja.
Seht ihr das hier irgendwo?
Nee, nee, nee. Ich bin nicht in der
UUCP-Gruppe, gell?
Okay, dann gehen wir jetzt einfach mal
Moment, was war nochmal der richtige
Also ich mach das
Ich muss sagen, ich bin oldschool
Ich trage die User einfach immer hier ein
Aber
So dass ich vergessen hab, wie das eigentlich war
Wie ging das nochmal
User Mod
Minus G, oder
Minus Add, Minus G
UU
CP, ey, ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, wie das funktioniert
Add, Current
Ja, da, A minus G, ist doch richtig
Und dann, Max
Okay, dann
Dann hatte ich ja doch fast richtig
Dann schauen wir doch mal hier rein
Bin ich denn jetzt in UUCP
Exquisite, ich bin in UUCP
Warte
UZP
Gucken wir nochmal.
Aber ich glaube, ich muss wahrscheinlich nochmal
die Shell-Session neu starten, dass es greift.
Dev.
USB.
TTY. USB.
Permission denied.
Okay, dann muss
ich eine neue Shell-Sitzung...
Reicht das, wenn ich einfach so mache?
Ne.
Oh, da gab es doch einen Trick.
So?
War das so?
Ja.
So muss man neue Shell Sessions starten.
Dann funktioniert das.
Okay, mein User hat schon mal Zugriff drauf.
Chat, dann.
Wisst ihr was? Wir probieren das einfach mal.
Das ist jetzt komplett, komplett
KI-Geschwubbel-Magic.
Aber
wir glauben es dem einfach mal.
Ich meine,
das ist das beste Coding-Model.
Was soll schon schief gehen?
Ups.
Ich mach mal kurz hier
ähm, ja, keine Ahnung.
CD-Repos.
Ne, CD-Temp.
Deswegen ein Bastel.
Heartbeat.py.
Set, Paste. Zack.
Bums. Bum.
So, rüber hier. Und jetzt probieren wir das mal aus.
nach temp
ca mod plus x
heartbeat.py
predictions
geht oder geht nicht
yes oder no
was mein ihr
nope geht
also ich tippe
geht nicht
Ah, ich weiß warum
Weil ich dumm bin
Weil ich das falsch ausgeführt habe
Python
ABPy
Okay, ja ja
Was muss ich installieren dafür?
PySerial, das da, C
Also ich würde das
Also bevor ich mir irgendwelche Pip-Packages installiere
Mache ich das auf jeden Fall in einem Container
Okay
Chat
Es macht Dinger, Moment
Ich ziehe mir die Uhr an
Es geht nicht
Nice
Moment, ist
TTY USB überhaupt
der richtige Stick?
Bevor ich da jetzt irgendeinen Mist erzähle
stand das überhaupt
in der Message drin?
Ja doch
doch
Okay
Nö
Also
Ich behalte
die Uhr mal an
Also das macht gar nichts.
Das juckt es nicht.
Gibt es vielleicht irgendwas,
wenn wir uns da fixen können?
Nee.
Ich denke nicht.
Okay, dann machen wir doch mal,
dann starten wir doch mal einen Container.
und
guck mal, wir haben doch hier noch den
Pi CLI Champ.
Den können wir doch
dafür verwenden.
Warum habe ich da den Linux Kernel ausgecheckt
drin? Vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben.
Jetzt machen wir mal wieder weg.
Okay, schon besser.
So.
Und da drin machen wir jetzt mal
hier die Open-End-Geschichten.
Also.
Ähm.
Ne, vorher muss ich da noch
das USB-Device reinmounten.
Wie macht man das mit
Dev-Container? Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Dev Container Mount
Device
Wie
Funds das?
Mount Source
Mount
Oder
Oder einfach
Oder muss man da einfach nur sagen
Mount
Source
Dass man dann quasi einfach nur sagen muss
Def
PTY USB 0
Nach
Def
USB 0
Fragezeichen
Ich weiß.
Das ist halt Blödsinn.
Wir gucken mal, ob das jetzt
Ob das jetzt so funktioniert
Keine Ahnung, lass uns mal probieren
Wir starten Pycharm
Hat er denn jetzt gemountet hier irgendwie?
Ach ne, da muss den Container erstmal bauen
Naja gut
Muss eine einmalige Sache
Also mein Plan ist folgender.
Wir lesen den Heartbeat aus über N+.
Und dann stellen wir einfach eine Webseite bereit, die den Heartbeat anzeigt, so wie das, was wir eben hier hatten.
Geht jetzt hier um den Erkenntnisgewinn, wie man das macht.
Das ist eine einmalige Sache mit dem Container bauen.
Wie gesagt, ich entwickle Sachen mittlerweile nur noch in Containern.
Und zwar mit DevPod.
Da ist man, sagen wir mal, zu 95% safe, wenn man es so macht wie ich, wenn man nicht gerade seinen Docker reinmountet.
Zu 95% safe von Supply Chain Angriffen, die sich ausbreiten.
Wovon man natürlich nicht safe ist, ist, das Ding hat immer noch Netzwerk-Access und sowas, ja.
Aber man ist erstmal safe davon, dass das Ding deine SSH-Keys uploadet.
Nach Russland.
Oder in die China-Cloud oder sonst wo.
Bind Mount Sources Path does not exist.
What?
Doch.
Okay, so geht das schon mal nicht.
I use
DevPod.
DevContainer
Jamel. Okay.
Es reimt sich wieder
irgendein Bullshit zusammen.
Es
DevContainer
Jason.
Okay, also sowas
soll ich hier machen. RunArgs.
Oh ja, wenn
Wenn die KI das sagt, dann muss das natürlich so sein.
Da sind wir uns ja einig.
Okay.
Dann starten wir das halt nochmal.
Gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Hm.
Ah, das hat jetzt wohl funktioniert.
Das hat wohl funktioniert.
Schauen wir mal, ob das Device da jetzt zur Verfügung steht.
Und dann probieren wir mal das hier aus.
Open End.
Ach ne, wir können ja Open End nicht ausprobieren, wenn wir nur das Serial Device geblindet haben.
Oh fuck, wie komme ich denn aus dem Container?
Da jetzt ruff.
Da muss ich mir das RAW-USB-Device in den Container mounten, hm?
Def, guck mal ob das Prinzip für TTY-USB...
Permission denied, geil!
Gut, und dieser komische Copy, ja da ist mein User natürlich nicht drin.
Das ist natürlich...
Das ist natürlich unpraktisch.
Open-End, gibt's das hier irgendwo?
Das gibt es als extra Python Package.
Wir müssen ja erstmal gucken, wie man den
Kram in den Container weiter durchreicht.
Die Idee hier oben
fand ich auch prinzipiell gar nicht
schlecht.
Mount.
Das da.
Also, dass man sagt,
guck hier.
If you are trying to access USB device
through DevBusUSB
dass wir das da brauchen.
Was ist
denn das?
Dev, Bus,
USB und da ist jetzt der Kram
hier drin. Okay, das ist
glaube ich die bessere Variante.
Dann machen wir jetzt nochmal das hier
und sagen dann, wir wollen
hier das da.
Dev, Bus, USB.
und greifen dann darauf zu
def usb
target
def usb auch und dann bind
habe ich jetzt dann habe ich denn dann rechte auf
der usb was war das def was gibt's einfach nicht ja ja super dass das wird
wieder das wird ein riesen act sagt ja mal richtig wie kriege ich ein fucking usb device
in den container durchgereicht so dass es dann da drin auch funktioniert jemand eine schlaue idee
muss es braucht es minus privileged vielleicht wirklich aber das will ich ja gar nicht ich will
We can privilege container starten.
Dev, Bus.
Ah ja, jetzt geht's.
Jetzt, jetzt
Funst. Habe ich jetzt, habe ich da drauf
Rechte drauf?
Dev, Bus, USB,
Kanal 3, 1.
Operation not permitted, weil
ich
doch.
Redrechte am alle.
Okay, das heißt, das sollte jetzt angeblich
funktionieren. Das heißt, ich kann
jetzt pip install
openend, aber
hier dev USB ist nicht da.
Pip install
pip not found, weil
Ah, Moment.
Das ist jetzt diese UX-Geschichte.
Ich bin Python-Noob.
Wie ging das jetzt?
UV?
Oh, shit.
UX?
Ne, wie heißt das?
UV?
Und dann add.
UV-Pip.
UV-Pip install.
So, ne?
Ne.
Okay, ich bin zu dumm dafür.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert.
UV-Sync.
Okay.
Das hat jetzt anscheinend funktioniert.
UV, Python.
Ähm, Run.
Äh.
Wie führe ich das denn jetzt aus?
Also ich muss jetzt ausführen.
Open End.
Achso.
Ux?
Ne, UV?
Und wie hat man dann irgendwas gestartet
damit jetzt?
Run.
Okay.
UV, Run, Python.
Das habe ich den hier am Start.
Open End.
Arguments required.
Open End scan.
Wow.
No Backend available.
Was genau bedeutet das jetzt?
USB-Core, no backend available?
Habe ich Sachen falsch weitergeleitet?
Lib-USB konnte er nicht finden.
Okay, das kann natürlich sein.
Also, upsearch, Lib-USB.
Lip USB Dev
Install Lip
Lip USB
Lip USB Dev
Installieren wir mal Header und geduldens mit
Okay, das gibt es nur das
Yes
Okay, und jetzt nochmal
Ha, Driver Not
Das ist jetzt was anderes
Driver Not For On
Wird ja immer besser
Means the Python
cannot detect or communicate with the end
USB-Stick.
Okay, geil.
Das liegt daran,
garantiert daran,
weil mein Docker-Zeug
oder muss ich jetzt
nochmal dieses, oder muss ich jetzt vorher noch
wirklich mal das hier machen?
Unbind.
Dass der das wieder frei gibt.
Okay, disconnected.
Wo geht's jetzt?
Haha, nein.
Tja.
Dann weiß ich jetzt wirklich nicht,
wie ich die ganzen Mist da rein mounte, Alter.
Wir hatten doch hier noch
ein Exempel hatten wir doch noch.
Wir mounten einfach komplett
Deaf, das können wir jetzt wirklich
Machen, wir mounten einfach
Komplett deaf, scheiß drauf
So
Was
Fuck mich ab, dass das nicht richtig geht
Ey
Okay, das geht nicht
Was?
DevTTY USB?
Das soll er doch überhaupt nicht mehr machen
Ah, ah, das ist noch das Run-Args
Das klingt falsch, gebe ich dir recht
Du sollst es überhaupt nicht adden.
Wie zum Teufel kommst du drauf, dass du...
Feitscha.
Also...
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht, irgendwelche Devices zu mounten in meinen Container zum entwickeln.
Deswegen.
Das seems like you don't have Chatbrains Gateway installed.
Habe ich nicht.
Dev.
Okay, jetzt haben wir diesen ganzen Krempel hier.
Das ist jetzt halt auch nicht so Sinn und Zweck der Übung.
Aber okay.
CLI Champ.
Also was mussten wir installieren?
App install lib
usb dev.
Genau.
Und jetzt mussten wir da nach App rein und haben gesagt
uvsync.
So.
Und dann war das andere wie
uv
run
openend.
Was?
Ah.
Das muss ich noch...
Das muss ich dem Projekt noch irgendwie hinzufügen.
Open end.
Scan.
Driver.
Alter, was willst du denn von mir?
Was hat das denn für Schmerzen, man?
Also, der kann irgendwie nicht...
Okay, wir machen mal was anderes.
Root. Bam.
So, wir haben komplett dev gemountet.
Also, wenn das jetzt nicht funzt, dann war ich out.
Wir machen das jetzt als Root im Container, okay?
UV-Run.
Not found.
Geil.
Weil?
Das ja nur für meinen User gilt.
Okay, dann machen wir das anders.
Kann ich denn sowas hier dann wenigstens machen?
Nee, natürlich nicht.
Home.
Meine.
Guck doch einfach, was das fehlt.
schlafen.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, da kann er nicht
drauf zugreifen. Da ist irgendwas Berechtigungsmäßiges
kaputt.
Dann sagen wir jetzt einfach hier
UV.
Run, Open, Scan.
Okay, das geht noch nicht
mal als root.
Das geht nicht mal
als root aktuell.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Wir machen jetzt mal eine Sache.
LibUSB.
Scheiß jetzt mal drauf.
UV installiert.
Ich installiere mir den Kram jetzt einfach mal hier.
Auf meinem Host.
Wurscht.
Wenn man Supply Chain detect.
UV pip install openend.
UV run openend scan.
Ja, das ist wenigstens was, wo man was mit anfangen kann.
Damit kann ich ja wenigstens was anfangen, Existinite.
Bei dem anderen ging das gar nicht.
Existinite ist ja noch okay.
Funst, Funst.
Okay.
Ha!
Guck mal da!
Hardrate!
Der hat was gefunden!
Nice!
So, und jetzt?
Die weiße IT...
Demo minus D120.
Inverted Choice Demo.
Geil.
Es lügt.
Okay, okay.
Aber er findet das. Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Jetzt ist nur noch die Frage...
Wie machen wir das?
Okay, nice. Nice, nice, nice.
Jetzt ist nur noch die Frage, wie machen wir das,
dass wir das jetzt im Container zum Laufen
bekommen?
Access USB from Container.
Ich will nicht zu USB, ich will zum Serial Device.
Ja, das weiß ich, dass das funktioniert.
Ah, vielleicht...
Ah ja.
Okay.
Das liegt daran, weil ich keine Rechte da drauf habe, ne?
Mit meinem User.
Aber das macht doch eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Weil der Docker-Demon läuft doch als Root.
Okay, dann probieren wir das nochmal aus.
Dann jetzt mit Privileged.
Das ist halt irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Nicht das, was ich haben will.
Privileged Dev-Container.
Aber nun gut.
auch in sus ok also probieren wir mal probiert probieren wir jetzt mal hier
Minus Minus.
Privilegiert.
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funzt.
Ähm.
Peitscharm.
Ah, da geht er auch nach Sus.
Ja, gut, dann.
rm-dev-container-jason, warum?
Warum sollte ich das löschen?
So.
Dev.
Was?
USB.
Okay.
So, nachdem ich keinen Bock habe, das jedes Mal neu zu machen,
App. So, wie addet man
mit UV denn jetzt nochmal Sachen
in Add?
UV Add
Open End
Okay, weil dann reicht es, wenn ich ein UV Sync
mache, dass es immer wieder da ist.
Ah.
Jetzt kann ich nämlich sagen, UV
Run
Open End Demo Scan.
War doch so, oder?
Äh, nicht Demo. Äh, Scan.
Okay, noch back.
Ah, ja. Ja, ja. Okay.
Das muss ich in meinen Container...
Das muss ich in meinen Container-Config schreiben.
Sonst vergesse ich das jedes Mal.
Permission not permitted?
Okay, sudo.
Not found? Ja, gut. Okay.
Ähm.
Das liegt jetzt daran,
dass ich keine Routerechte habe.
Meiner Wegen, okay.
Gab es nicht eine Möglichkeit,
dass man seinen Path mit Sudo mitnimmt?
Sudo, Preserve,
Path.
Ging doch irgendwie.
You can always do
sudo env...
Okay.
Aber jetzt geht Minus I nicht mehr, ne?
Muss ich jetzt quasi sagen, bash.
Ah, shoot. Aber UV funzt
jetzt.
UV run
open and scan.
Es funzt!
Es funzt, Leute.
Hardbeat-Sensor found.
Okay, gibt's irgendwie die Möglichkeit,
dass man das auch machen kann,
als nicht root? Brauch ich da...
Da brauch ich bestimmt irgendeine super hässliche
UDEF-Rule, hä?
DEF was?
Ich mein, read?
Read hab ich ja schon als
anderer User da drauf.
Und ich würde mal drauf tippen...
Read reicht doch für nen Scan, oder nett?
Aber vielleicht...
Sys...
Was...
USB...
Ja gut, da ist halt...
Da ist halt...
Devices...
3...
Das ist halt gut.
Da kannst du... Okay.
Jetzt halt die Frage, wie kann man...
Wie könnte man das machen, dass man dann nicht root sein muss für...
Also mich fuckt's ab, dass ich einen Privileged Container brauche, aber das...
DHBot777, ja gut.
Das würde ich aber ungern machen.
Na gut, jetzt zum Basteln ist das doch erstmal kein Problem, oder?
Jetzt zum Basteln ist das doch erstmal wurscht.
Das Problem können wir anderweitig fixen.
Das können wir anderweitig fixen. Das ist kein Ding.
Seems like you don't have Chatbrains Gateway installed on your computer.
Die habe ich nicht.
Wirklich nicht?
Äh, ich hab...
Natürlich hab ich
Chatpoints-Gateway installiert.
Ist das vielleicht broken?
Fragezeichen seit dem letzten Update.
Ich öffne
das mal in Goland. Einfach mal zum Checken,
ob das prinzipiell funktionieren würde.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck,
der ist seit dem letzten Update,
das ist ein bisschen kaputt.
Es könnte natürlich auch sein,
weil ich habe gerade eben geupdatet,
es könnte natürlich auch sein,
dass wir rebooten müssen,
dass das funktioniert.
Das machen wir jetzt mal.
Wir rebooten jetzt.
Daran liegt es bestimmt.
Seems like you don't have
Chatbron's Gateway installed on your computer.
Doch, doch, hab ich doch.
Okay, das
funktioniert nicht.
Wir rebooten mal.
Das kann auf jeden Fall nichts schaden.
Moin.
Reboot.
Auf Mini-PC.
Mach.
Reboote.
Wo ist das Problem?
Top Secret Password.
Nicht möglich zu erraten.
So, da sind wir wieder.
Ich hoffe, der verbindet sich jetzt so weit, dass alles wieder funktioniert.
Zack. Jawohl, da sind wir.
Okay.
Dann gehen wir nochmal hier rein.
Repos, Pi, CLI-Champ.
Mal schauen, ob es jetzt funktioniert mit Pi-Charm.
Postchamp?
Postchamp? Ah!
Okay.
Reboot hat es gefixt, Leute.
Massive Reboot.
...
Macht das was?
Und das jetzt?
Starting Scanner?
Der findet kein
Device mehr.
Ah, das liegt daran, weil ich
das andere nicht unbindet habe.
Das liegt bestimmt daran...
Ja, weil ich...
Ich muss doch bei dem anderen...
Muss ich doch...
Besser machen.
Unbind.
Hier, TTY-USB.
Äh, warum ging das jetzt eben nicht?
Ah, weil das Device falsch ist.
Alter, ist das...
Guck mal.
Eins, zwei, eins.
Moment, disconnected?
Ja, wie jetzt? Hä?
Ach, jetzt ist es disconnected.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt kein
DevTTY
USB. Okay.
Hä?
Der findet meinen Heartbeat-Sensor aber nicht.
Ah, jetzt hat er es. Okay, ich habe nichts gesagt, Leute.
Ich habe nichts gesagt. Er hat einfach nur ein bisschen gebraucht,
Heartbeat-Sensor zu finden.
Gut. Okay, das Funst.
Ich bin
begeistert.
High-Sementeffekt.
Wir können jetzt uns das mal angucken.
Das ist das Scanner-Example.
Wobei, wollen wir das
wirklich in Python machen?
Python ist immer so pain in the ass zu
zu
distributen.
Mach in Go.
Wir probieren es mal in Go aus.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob es in Go
eine gescheite Library gibt.
Ja, weil, ich sag mal so, ich hab in Go
diese Library hier gefunden.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob die das macht, was wir wollen.
Hier, die da.
Also die Python Library sieht mit Abstand am besten aus.
Hier, Go End.
Hat halt 8 Sterne und zuletzt aktualisiert vor 8 Monaten.
Ach, Copy Paste geht wieder nicht.
Geil.
Go End GitHub.
Wasser.
Wir können es ausprobieren.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt zwar ein Container, wo ich
Heißen Gedöns
drinnen. Wir machen jetzt mal an.
Eine Sache machen wir jetzt noch. Wir connecten
uns jetzt mit Goland. Okay? Immerhin.
Das schadet auf jeden Fall nichts.
Aber letztendlich ist es...
Gucken wir nochmal.
Scan.
Äh, Timeout?
Was?
Warum timeoutet das gerade?
Das ist ein bisschen hakelig, ne?
Ich will keine Lizenz
beien.
Oh fuck, ich bin ja hier nicht eingeloggt
Nein, shit
Was mache ich denn da jetzt?
Also heute ist das wirklich alles gegen uns
Okay, warte mal
Es gab doch einen Trick
Wartet mal
Konfig?
Jetbrain?
Jetbrains.
Irgendwas Gescheites.
Konfig oder so?
Warte mal, ich hab doch in der
History vorhin was gehabt. History
less
irgendwie Bloop Jetbrains
oder so. Wo sind wir denn
dahin? Wir waren
in welchem Verzeichnis waren wir denn da?
Waren wir denn da, als ich das gemacht
hab? Jetbrains, Bloop.
Hier.
Konfig Jetbrains.
Jetbrains nach
keckel so und hoffentlich hoffentlich habe ich jetzt glück und das hat mein
beta zeitraum gesettet regel chat präge präge
apropos max wald moment was war die frage
kennst du das puls loup projekt auf github die lesen so china chinesen smart
Ringe aus, um günstige Alternativen zu
woop und so. Ne, das kenn ich nicht.
Leute.
Unsere Trial ist
resettet. Alles, alles wieder gut.
Easy.
Es ist, es ist nice.
Es ist nice, wie einfach
die Trials zu resetten sind.
Aber wie gesagt, ich hab
nen All-Desktop-Subscription, ja.
Bin hier bloß nicht eingeloggt.
Ich hab's auch, ihr habt's auch im Stream-Tour oft genug gesehen, dass ich eine Subscription hab.
Ja, free trial.
Okay, dann, dann gehen wir jetzt mal hier raus.
Ähm, mal MKD, Go-App.
Upt, Install, Go.
Sudo, up, install, go.
Golang?
Fragezeichen.
1, 2, 4. Das ist ziemlich alt, oder?
Golang, 1, 2, 4.
Aber das ist Debian Trixi.
Das ist, ja.
Nix, install, golang.
Ich weiß, wo ich mir das abgucken kann.
Ich habe doch hier Repos,
Templates. Ich hab doch auch was für Go-Programme.
Ich bin das so zu faul, einen neuen Container zu starten.
Hier ein Docker-File.
Nix Env minus...
Nee.
Hab nix gesagt.
Ey, wie genau installe ich Go in meinem Go-Template?
Gar nicht?
Oder was?
Nix Packages.
Hä?
Aber mach ich...
Go kommt durch Space Image?
Das wäre ja richtig hängen geblieben.
Warum sollte ich denn das machen?
Nö.
Moment, in meinem Go-Projekt wird überhaupt kein Go installiert.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Sehr schlau, Max.
Excellent.
Hi, IQ.
Oh, da haben wir nochmal ein Template-Stocker-File.
Okay.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Ah ne, das ist das Docker-File Base.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen...
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen installiere ich...
Installiere ich in meinem Docker-Template kein...
In meinem Go-Template kein Go.
Okay, das ist ziemlich dumm.
aber okay kann ich mit leben wir können auch mit go 124 leben das
überhaupt kein problem install go lang so ob kein ding
durchs in it vielleicht
Nö.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
So, hier haben wir es.
Jetzt haben wir Go am Start.
Dann können wir das öffnen.
Gehen mal hier hin.
Sagen Open
Workspaces Go App.
Da ist natürlich noch nichts drin.
Dann initialisen
Visualisieren wir jetzt hier mal eine Go-App.
Init Go-App.
Das habe ich jetzt natürlich alles nicht drin.
Sehr schlau von mir gewesen.
Ich hätte vielleicht doch das Go-Image verwenden sollen.
Go-Mod Init.
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen.
Ich will New.
Project.
In.
Nein.
in...
Kommt da da drauf? In Workspaces?
Oh Gott,
jetzt geht da nochmal das Auto komplett, Alter.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich will das in Workspaces.
Sag mal.
Ist die IDE richtig hängen geblieben gerade?
Kann das sein?
Alter, warum ist das so kaputt?
Workspaces.
Go, ähm, da.
Da sollste.
Wendering, was auch immer.
Wir wollen auf jeden Fall eine ganz normale Go-Anwendung mit Go-Mods und Gedöns machen.
It's not empty. Ja meinetwegen, from existing resources, von mir auch recht sein.
Gut, da sind wir.
Wenn wir das Ganze mal kurz starten und machen die Schriftgröße ein bisschen größer.
Font Size.
Mouse Wheel.
Gut, dieses ganze Ding hier.
FMT.
Log.
Ne, Print.
Go.
Ich stell's.
Print.
Printlein.
Lul.
Okay, gut.
Dann schauen wir mal, ob Go an sich funktioniert.
Go, Run.
Das da.
Kompilier-Stells.
Und jetzt?
Lull.
Okay, Fonst.
Gut.
Also, wie Fonst das denn hier jetzt?
Import to Project.
Ja.
Machen wir.
Will er nicht, weil das immer rumpackt.
Muss man so machen, glaube ich, dass das funktioniert.
Musste man nicht, konnte man nicht so machen, dass er das immer trotzdem importiert?
Fix missing dependencies, jawohl.
Go USB.
Okay, next.
Ich werde einfach mal hier komplett diesen Kerntel reinpasten und schauen wir mal.
Okay, schauen wir mal, was er macht.
Def.
Get device def das geht ja schon mal gut los das geht ja schon mal gut los mit dieser mit der mit der library hier
Not enough arguments warum weil ich weil wir einen channel brauchen ok
Anhändelt er sollte sollten wir handeln
log.error
Nee, wie ging das nochmal?
Nee, slog ist es, oder?
Error?
No message.
Ja, bam.
Also das hier mag er nicht.
Der braucht einen Channel.
Okay, für was?
Für was brauchen wir denn einen Channel?
Was macht der damit?
Ach, Message. Die Messages kommen da drüber.
Also, Dev Channel.
Äh, so?
Fragezeichen?
Ähm, da bin ich jetzt
zu lange raus aus Go.
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht mehr.
Wie geht...
Wie war dann die Syntax?
Konnte man jetzt da so hinten dran machen?
Nee.
Okay, warte mal.
Channel go inline.
So quasi als alt Callback.
Das ist dann das mit den Pfeilen und so, ne?
Messages make channel.
Okay.
Ja.
Messages.
Und dann muss man hier sagen Messages.
Okay, das funzt.
Start.
Okay.
Das Ding ist, keine Ahnung, ob das hier auch nur ansatzweise funktioniert.
Wir starten das jetzt einfach.
Go run.
Das geht jetzt nicht, weil wir keine Rechte haben.
Ja.
Package libUSB was not found.
Wie?
Hab ich doch.
sudo apt install libUSB
Ist doch installiert.
Okay, das ist mit Go Library fällt schon mal flach.
Das ist schon mal dumm.
Schon mal richtig hängen geblieben, oder?
Ach, kann das sein, dass ich eine ältere LibUSB-Version dafür brauche?
Aha, guck mal, ich brauche
LibUSB...
Ich brauche LibUSB
1.
Anscheinend.
Okay, das ist wieder abenteuerlich.
Yes.
Okay, jetzt, Fragezeichen, geht's jetzt?
Error. Bam.
Okay, was ist denn
der Error?
Was?
Cannot use Error.
Wie, warum kann ich kein Error mit Error
loggen?
Äh.
War das so?
Ich weiß nicht, aber es gab da irgendeinen Trick dafür.
Äh, Moment.
Wir müssen nachgucken.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das hier schon hatten.
Go.
Ist das Go?
Ne, pressen.
Ach, Punkt, Error.
Der checkt das bloß nicht, oder was?
Das ist die Message.
Ja, das ist trotzdem auch mal so durch die Brust ins Auge.
Bad Axis.
Okay.
Sudo davor.
Aha.
Guck mal, hat schon Dinger gemacht.
Read End Message.
So, und jetzt will ich...
Jetzt will ich doch hier unten...
Hier unten will ich doch jetzt eigentlich
eine Endlosschleife machen über Messages.
So?
Oh fuck, ich weiß nicht mal, wie das funktioniert.
Go funk messages ping.
Moment, was macht der Kram nochmal?
Das läuft
asynchron?
Synchron?
Okay, das hier
wartet auf eine Message, ne?
Das hier sendet ne Message.
Das sendet ne Message.
Und das hier wartet auf eine Message.
Go endless read from channel.
Ah, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Genau, das habe ich gesucht.
From messages.
Print Message.
Okay, run.
Also der
readet irgendwas.
Jetzt nur das Ding,
woher weiß ich, dass der das Richtige readet?
Also da ist die Python Library
deutlich angenehmer gewesen.
Aber wir kriegen das schon raus.
Hier hat doch
irgendwie einer so ein Example
Example gehabt. Guckt mal hier, oder?
Das ist super krass. Maintain the library hier, ne?
Read end message.
Also wir machen das ja hier
wahrscheinlich das hier schon mal verkehrt, ne?
End plus
Network Key.
Okay, das ist irgendein Spezial-Key,
der für alle gleich ist anscheinend.
Ist es denn überhaupt das richtige USB-Device, was ich hier aufmache?
Get USB-Device.
Schauen wir mal.
LS.
USB.
So, wir haben 0FCF.
0FCF.
1008.
Okay.
Das ist das richtige Device.
Auf jeden Fall.
So.
Und jetzt macht er was?
Also was hat der Dude hier gemacht?
Bla bla bla?
Bla bla?
Set Network Key?
Das haben wir auch alles gemacht.
Set Channel ID.
Ah ja!
Okay, okay, das wollen wir nicht.
Wir wollen Set Channel ID.
Device Type.
Ähm, was ist denn?
End plus Device Type.
Ich hab doch hier irgendwo einen Inam-Freund gesehen.
Device Type ID List.
11 ist Power.
Heart Rate.
Ach, das ist die 120 von vorhin gewesen, Leute.
Das war die 120 von vorher.
Ich verstehe.
In welchem Format müssen wir das übrigens hier übergeben?
120 oder irgendwie...
Device Type.
Na gut, gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
120.
Transmission Type.
Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer, was das sein muss.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Zoodo Run.
Bam.
Also der readet schon Messages.
Aber dann hört er auf.
Ah!
Was ist das?
LibUSB interrupted.
Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Ich tippe drauf, dass das nicht so geil ist.
Ich lass das jetzt mal kurz laufen.
Also, Chat, ich
habe den Eindruck,
das funzt nicht.
Und by the way,
that channel period, was bedeutet das?
Ich hab ne Idee
Guck mal, ich hatte doch vorhin so ein
So ein .NET
Programm gefunden
And plus
Examples
USB Stick
So, und da hatten die doch
Irgendein
Ex-
Bei Open End stand bei Transmission Typ, glaube ich, 209.
Okay.
Also, das ist eindeutig zu raw hier.
Transmission Type?
Okay, warte mal.
End Plus Transmission Type.
Transmission Time.
Lift.
What?
Alter, das ist ja richtig high IQ.
Sicher, dass es 209 war? Wir können das mal ausprobieren.
Ja.
Transmission type values.
Okay, broadcast, advanced burst, burst.
128 hätten wir zu bieten.
192.
List all.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Aber wenn du sagst, es war 209,
dann mache ich das jetzt einfach mal.
Es war 209, okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Juckt ihr nicht?
Also ganz ehrlich.
Ich könnte einen E-Namen generieren lassen.
ist schön und gut, aber ich muss erstmal
irgendwas rauskriegen, bevor ich da weiter
in das Go-Ding stecke.
Also das Go-Ding funzt nicht.
Also da gibt es keine gescheite Library,
die das kann.
So, wir können jetzt nochmal...
Ich bekomme
keine Werte von meinem
Hard-B-Sensor.
Einfach mal auf gut Glück.
Keine Ahnung, ob das irgendwas Sinnvolles raus ist.
Zwei entscheidende Punkte.
Aha.
Solltest du zunächst
einen normalen X-Kanal konfigurieren
mit dem Open Channel 0.
Was?
Period.
8, 0, 7, 0.
8, 0, 7, 0. Okay.
Okay.
Ich habe fast alles richtig gemacht.
Okay, dummes...
Die Weißnummer?
Oh.
Ja, Moment. Das ist doch genau das, was ich hier auch habe.
was er hier sagt.
Okay, man soll hier 0 angeben.
Aber ich lasse da mal 209.
Device ID ist wieder was anderes.
Okay, das können wir tatsächlich machen.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt.
Das sieht ein bisschen besser aus.
Und wir können die Messages auch durchaus mal
bounden auf 100.
Das ist auch okay.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendwas bringt.
Der empfängt einfach nichts.
Okay, wir fragen mal
Opus, okay?
Weil ich bin da wirklich komplett lost.
Ich will
das hier benutzen.
In Go.
Ah geil, ich hab jetzt, ich hab natürlich jetzt kein Code.
Es ist halt dumm, dass ich nicht copy-pasten kann gescheit da draus.
Moment, hat er eine andere IP gekriegt?
Also das, guck mal hier, das funzt nicht, das wagt rum.
SSHD starten.
Zack.
So.
Wo sind wir hier unterwegs?
Repos, Pi, CLI, Champ,
Go App
und jetzt Main.
Main.go. Excellent.
Aber es liest
keine Hardbeat-Werte
aus.
Also ich glaube, die Library ist einfach
Crap.
Der Transmission-Typ
ist falsch. Okay.
Also der Transmission-Typ muss
0 sein.
Warum? Weil Magic.
Warum
wobbelt das eigentlich so
wie dumm hier rum?
Ich nur...
Hör mal auf hier so rum zu wobbeln.
Warum benutzt du nicht...
Ich habe sogar Open Code installiert.
Open Rx Scan Mode.
Ignoriert deine Channel-Konfiguration teilweise.
Ach, so ist das so.
Er ignoriert die Channel-Period komplett.
Er hört durchgehend zu.
Deshalb Continuous.
Kein anderer Channel darf offen sein.
Der Stick kann diesen Modus nicht senden.
Für einen Einzelnen willst du Scan-Modus gar nicht.
Nimm den normalen Weg.
Open Channel 0.
What?
Was?
Okay, was soll ich machen?
Open AX Scan Mode.
Das mache ich doch überhaupt nicht.
Ach doch.
Ach so, soll ich das weglassen, oder wie?
Und dafür soll ich machen
End Open Channel 0, oder was?
Und das ist jetzt besser?
fehlerprüfung warten auf responses
okay das ist eine gute idee das kann man natürlich machen was antwort auf jeden
konzern einem channel response event die einen return call wenn du zum beispiel
Beispiel sein Network Key mit...
Was macht dann eigentlich
Reset System? Macht das überhaupt Sinn?
Achso, ich reset das am Anfang einmal.
Okay, das kann man tatsächlich machen.
Time Sleep, das ist nicht verkehrt.
Ähm, ne Sekunde.
Sekunde Sleep ist in Ordnung.
Was?
Aber ich hab doch hier nie Return Werte.
Das ist doch Blödsinn. Ich bekomm die doch aus dem...
Da halluziniert sich das
jetzt gerade was zusammen.
Ich prüfe doch die...
Return-Werte gibt es ja hier nicht.
Die haben ja keine Return-Werte.
Diese Functions.
Ah, die haben keine Return-Werte.
Und ich bekomme ja hier Messages.
Das ist okay.
Ich weiß aber halt nicht, welche Messages...
Doppelte Import.
Ja, juckt nicht.
Okay, haben wir gemacht.
Haben wir gemacht. Also im Prinzip alles
richtig.
Okay.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt von's...
Ha?
Nee. Okay, ist von's nicht.
Ich hätte schon fast gedacht,
es geht. Ups. Ich hätte schon fast
gedacht, es geht. Das Ding ist,
wir müssten jetzt diese Messages hier irgendwie
decoden, um zu wissen,
was die bedeuten, aber das unterstützt diese Go-Library nicht. Ganz ehrlich, das ist super krasser Low-Level-Shit.
Das...
Oh!
Was ist das hier?
Der überträgt aber ganz schön langsam, oder?
Wenn er nur in diesem Abstand Herzfrequenzen...
Okay, wir haben...
Einfach mal random hinschmeißen.
Okay, aber jetzt...
Das ist verbuggter Kram.
Ich glaube, in diese Go-Library
da noch ein bisschen mehr Energie reinzustecken.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich schweiß nicht.
Das macht irgendwie keinen so guten Eindruck.
Moment.
Chat-GPT weiß angeblich,
weiß angeblich, was das ist.
Okay, und hier ist wieder...
Okay, das ist wieder Channel Closed.
Search Timeout.
Okay.
Channel ID.
Das ist doch Blödsinn, oder?
Das ist Chat-GPT, was
irgendwas zusammen halluziniert.
Hm, also so gerne ich das
So gerne ich das jetzt hier in Go machen würde
Ich
Irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, dass
Fonds nicht so richtig
Ja, der hier hat ja auch Probleme, ne?
Der kriegt auch nichts
But no data is being received after that
Und da wurde auch nicht
Darauf geantwortet
Vielleicht ist die Library einfach broken
Vielleicht geht die Library einfach nicht
Das kann ja auch sein
Dass die einfach nie funktioniert hat
Wirkliche Examples
Wirklich gescheite Examples
Gibt es ja im Endeffekt auch nicht
Wir können es nochmal kurz rückgängig machen, ob da...
The Reset System.
Ob da jetzt irgendwas drin ist.
Aber ich glaube, das ist...
Nee, das ist das Broken.
Das ist nix.
Ne, da kommt auch nix.
Also, vielleicht geht die auch
und ich bin zu dumm dafür, das
zu benutzen, aber da gibt es halt
überhaupt kein
Beispiel für.
hat es ist opus irgendwas gescheites eingefallen
auch nichts also das ist für mich nicht so wirklich ersichtlich
wie das funktioniert
Ich find's auch irgendwie
Merkwürdig, dass der Zwischendurch immer Timeoutet
Ne, man findet nicht viel
Ich hab auch schon hier
Wenn du suchst GitLab and plus
Go
Dann findest du das
Du findest das
Aber das hab ich
Da hast du gar keine Exempel
Das hab ich auch gefunden
Das hab ich auch gefunden, aber da hast du gar keine Exempels
Du hast einfach null Ahnung, wie es überhaupt funktioniert.
Also das ist komplett unusable, weil du weißt halt gar nichts.
Du hast kein Exempel oder irgendwas.
Es gibt halt überhaupt kein
Exempel.
Sample.
Read.
Heartbeat.
Sensor.
C-Sharp. C-Sharp habe ich was gefunden.
C-Sharp ist aber Windows-Only,
so wie es aussieht.
Yes.
Mach mal, JetKPT.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was das sagt.
Okay.
Ey.
Wenn das...
Wenn ChatGP dir das sagt...
Das funzt doch...
Das funzt doch im Leben nicht.
Das im Leben...
Okay, das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren.
Das Fundstock im Leben nicht, Alter.
Hallo?
Im Leben...
Da sind bestimmt schon Syntaxfehler jetzt drin, ne?
Ja, geil.
Achso, okay.
Ich hab nichts gesagt.
Fixed Missing Imports.
Okay, immerhin keine Syntaxfehler.
Okay, warum nicht?
Warum nicht? Weil...
Autodetect.
Nee, Prediction ist
too late. Er findet
schon mal keinen USB-Stick.
USB?
Get device?
Okay, das hatten wir doch vorher.
Das haben wir doch vorher.
ID?
Was war das?
LS? LS USB?
Ne, war da.
Hier.
Ja.
0F 0F?
Irgendwas?
Muss das ein String sein, oder was?
Was muss das sein?
Man weiß das
nicht genau.
Was muss es denn sein?
Eine Go...
Go-Sub...
ID.
Hä?
Was zum...
Was muss das sein?
Go-USB-ID.
Go...
USB...
ID.
Okay.
Macht man das so in Go?
Ja, das funzt.
So.
Und dann?
Acht.
Okay.
So, und jetzt kann ich das wahrscheinlich so hier benutzen.
So, schauen wir mal.
Oh.
Oh!
Leute!
Alter!
Das geht einfach!
Wie es einfach
Das hat doch random funktioniert.
Da haben wir Hard-Vibe-Coded jetzt, hä?
Jetzt noch kurz zum Check ein Rage-Modus.
Lass mal gucken, was das jetzt anders macht.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Ja, das gefällt mir.
Also, ich werde das jetzt nicht einfach hier so blind übernehmen,
sondern wir müssen uns schon ein bisschen angucken, was das macht.
also usb get device braucht das denn überhaupt für get device braucht das denn
moment leute ich habe kann das sein dass sie eine eigene implementierung haben und gar
nicht lip usb brauchen lasst uns das mal ganz kurz mal hier auswählen go bild
C-Go, wie war das?
C-Go
enabled gleich 0.
Gucken, dann ist das nämlich richtig schön portable.
Äh.
Okay, nee. Ohne C-Go
funktioniert das nicht. Also
Go-USB ist anscheinend ein
Wrapper für Lib-USB.
Vermute ich jetzt mal so.
Ja, weil da Lib-USB-Kontext
und so. Also C-Go des Ablen
funktioniert nicht. Leider, leider, leider, leider.
Das wäre natürlich mega nice gewesen.
Aber wir schauen uns trotzdem mal an.
Alter, geh weg. Gibt es
LibUSB
Pure Go?
Aha.
Sieben Jahre.
Go Bindings for C-Lib USB.
Okay, man braucht diese 1.0er.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen wollen die immer diese 1.0er haben.
Ne, warte mal.
Wir benutzen das hier.
Wir benutzen Google Go USB, ne?
Lib USB 1.0.
Okay, okay.
So, dann lass uns doch mal kurz checken.
Was macht, was macht denn dieses Ding hier über?
Ups, Moment, Moment.
Da will ich jetzt, ich will da hier nicht,
ich will nicht da drin rumeditieren.
Was, was macht denn dieses Teil hier?
Also.
USB Get Device.
Gut.
das check ich das haben wir bei dem anderen auch gemacht usb signal found und ansonsten egal was
ist immer stick close soweit auch okay n plus tick found scan if i had bit sensors configuring
n plus receive scan mode start scan mode das haben wir bei dem anderen auch gemacht da haben
eine Sekunde gewartet danach.
Und dann macht er
Notify Context.
Dann macht er einen Channel.
Wofür braucht er den Kontext?
Dump Broadcast
Messages.
Ähm.
Das braucht der? Für was?
Dass der ordentlich
Ctrl-C und alles handelt
Oder wie ist das? Wie darf ich das hier jetzt verstehen?
Ist das, dass der ordentlich
Ctrl-C und so handelt? Also das
Das ist quasi Cancellation-Token in C-Sharp
Also wie Cancellation-Token
In .NET
Oder? Fragezeichen
Okay, N plus Hard-Red-Sensors
Ich will nicht alles in Chat-GPT
Wir müssen den High IQ des Chats ja auch mal beibehalten.
If Message Device Time nicht 120, das heißt nur wenn es ein Hardbit-Sensor ist, wenn Data kleiner 8 ist.
Okay.
Ja, das ist doch, das ist doch an sich, ist das doch sehr übersichtlich hier, oder?
Da kann man doch nichts dagegen sagen.
Ja, dann machen wir das Ganze doch in Go.
Ähm.
Ich muss mir kurz noch was zu trinken holen und dann aufs Klo.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start.
Ja, dass ihr was zu gucken habt.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Wieder am Start.
Was wollte ich jetzt nochmal gucken hier, was das da macht, ne?
Wofür ist dieser
CTX?
CTX ist für das Saumas
beziehungsweise gesagt, was passiert,
erstellt einen Kontext, der automatisch, wenn, wenn,
CTRL-C, siehste, hab ich doch recht gehabt,
CTRL-C ist das.
Chat, ich bin schon mal begeistert,
dass das jetzt einfach so funktioniert hat.
Also für sowas ist KI echt praktisch,
weil dieses Projekt
hat ja überhaupt
eine
Beispielprojekte,
keine Codesamples, keine Doku,
nix.
Noch einfach, man könnte sich TTR als Stoppsignal vorstellen.
Warte.
Okay, whatever.
Gut, ähm.
Tim, Tim, Tim, Tim, Tim, Tim.
Dann versuchen wir das doch mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen schöner, Go-mäßig schöner zu machen.
Also, das Ziel ist jetzt ja folgendes.
Ich will das auslesen und dann an eine Webseite schicken.
Das heißt, wir brauchen sowas wie Websockets wahrscheinlich.
Wobei, nee, scheiße, wir brauchen keine Websockets.
Wir pollen.
Wir pollen einfach einmal die Sekunde.
Einmal die Sekunde pollen, okay?
Das ist schon okay.
Paul Champ.
Wir brauchen Websockets.
Aber warum?
Einmal Sekunde Pollen geht doch.
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht mal was.
Okay, Chat, Chat, ihr dürft entscheiden.
Wir haben Zeit.
Websockets oder eine Sekunde Pollen?
Ich muss das, ich muss das erst nochmal kurz hier verstehen.
Und.
Also überlegt euch, ja.
Ob wir Websockets finden
Oder einfach so
Okay, ich seh schon
Ich muss das erstmal verstehen
Also das hier ist relativ easy
Stick-Close macht auch Sinn
Macht das nicht sogar mehr Sinn
Jetzt mal blöde Sachen, ne
So, ach nee, Stick ist ja
Vielleicht nicht belegt
Okay, nee, macht keinen Sinn
Macht keinen Sinn.
Okay.
Also, dann machen wir das jetzt erstmal.
Was ist das Ziel?
Ich kann es dir zeigen.
Guck mal.
Das hier mit Aftloh stimmt übrigens gar nicht.
Ich habe hier meine Uhr an.
Ups.
Äh.
Chat, jetzt habe ich was falsch gemacht.
Okay.
Äh, ich hab hier ne Uhr an.
Chat, was hab ich geändert?
Warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr?
Fuck!
Ich hab da überhaupt nix, ich hab da überhaupt nix gemacht.
Ich hab da noch gar nix geändert.
Ich muss so nen Reset machen.
Nee, nee, C-Go habe ich nicht gemacht.
Scanning Far-Trade-Sensors.
Also, ich will von meiner Garmin-Uhr, das hat eben auch funktioniert,
ich will von meiner Garmin-Uhr meine Herzfrequenz auslesen.
Und das hat funktioniert.
Nochmal den Code von ChatGPT kopieren.
Okay, ja, ist recht.
Ist das dumm?
Was habe ich denn?
Irgendwas muss ich jetzt falsch gemacht haben.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, dass die ein lokales streamen.
Okay, Chad, aus irgendwelchen Gründen
ist
das einmalig
und jetzt kaputt.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil der kein Reset
gemacht hat. Der muss auch einen Reset
machen, wie das andere das
gemacht hat. Also
ist die Uhr noch irgendwie verbunden?
Die schickt Wireless-Signale.
Stick, Reset.
Wir müssen so ein Reset machen, wie bei dem anderen auch.
Garantiert.
Nur Close alleine reicht nicht.
Reset System.
Wie könnte man das hier machen?
USB?
Tick Slip USB Lock.
Okay, was auch immer.
Wir hatten es eben schon laufen.
Also es ging eben schon mal.
Scanning for Heart Rate Sensors.
Wir haben es irgendwie kaputt gemacht,
dadurch, dass wir es neu gestartet haben.
Wie war es?
Reset.
Das ist gut.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Reset Wait und Reset bei dem einen Sender, der es nur bei dem anderen wartet?
Right, Reset.
And System Reset Message.
Okay, ich wette mit euch, das müssen wir machen, damit das Ding wieder geht.
Reset Wait.
Driver, Stick.
Das müssen wir machen.
Und dann müssen wir hier Handle Error machen.
ach so ja das ist logik
lockt fehlte
ja genau ist das
okay das das geht nicht mehr
Es ging einmal und dann war es kaputt.
Nun, das ist in der Tat doof.
Also das ist jetzt nicht so stable.
Die Uhr neu starten.
Ne, an der Uhr liegt das nicht.
Das liegt an dem USB-Stick.
Also Radiosignale.
Das Ding ist, ich habe einen AND-Plus-USB-Stick.
Der versteht dieses proprietäre Garmin-Protokoll.
Kopiere nochmal den Code.
Hab ich doch eben.
Habe ich doch eben gemacht.
Hat nichts gebracht.
So.
Also was könnte
das Problem sein?
Wir machen mal folgendes.
Wir sagen hier mal
log
oder slog
info
message
Achso gut, da muss man jetzt hier natürlich
äh
device type string, keine Ahnung.
Ob der überhaupt was macht.
Der macht gar nichts.
Stick reconnecten.
Ja, das funktioniert bestimmt auch.
Aber.
Was das Ziel ist.
Das Ziel ist folgendes.
Das Ziel ist das hier.
Im Prinzip sowas ähnliches.
Nur.
Proprietäres Garmel Protokoll.
Aber Deadman Switch ist auch eine gute Idee.
Also das frunzt so schon mal nett.
scanning vor da hört er auf ok dann machen wir noch mal hier in den kurzen
lockt die fnt print ist mir vollkommen egal ob das überhaupt bis hierhin kommt
kommt es nämlich nicht das hängt das hängt beim reset oder das hängt beim
reset leute ich sag's euch was auf das hängt beim reset das hängt beim reset
ja ihr seid weight heck weight macht es
Das hier, da hängt er.
End System Reset Message.
Okay, wir machen mal so einen Reset.
Kommt da ein Error?
Hängt der wieder komplett jetzt, oder?
Der hängt.
Guckt mal, Leute. Der hängt komplett.
Selbst wenn er das einfach nur
senden soll. Der ist komplett
dead, broken.
Muss man vielleicht irgendwie USB resetten?
Geht sowas vielleicht, dass man sagt?
Stick?
Close.
Ja gut, das ist aber halt
bisschen dumm, weil
wenn ich sage
stick close, dann
Moment, ich kann den stick closen und
trotzdem geht das dann weiter?
Ja, also
es liegt auf jeden Fall an dem Reset,
dass das hier rumspackt.
Und wir haben halt
eine Library, die ist, würde ich mal sagen,
nicht sonderlich testet.
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein Bug.
Wahrscheinlich ist es
ein Bug, dass wenn er hier Reset
sendet.
Driver Riot.
Hängt er denn bei jedem?
Stick Riot.
Hängt er denn bei allem?
Wir rioten jetzt mal irgendeinen random
Shit, okay? Eins.
Okay.
Ganz toll.
Moment, wie gehen wir...
Oh, fuck. Go.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal? So?
So? Eins?
Nee. Make. Make, oder?
Make.
Okay.
Unused variable write.
Was returnt der denn?
Was returnt der als write?
Der returnt quasi,
wie viel er
geritet hat.
Mal gucken, ob der jetzt...
Mal gucken, ob der immer noch jetzt wieder an der Stelle hängt.
Ja, guck mal.
Guck mal.
Wann wir wieder durch den Schnee gestellt...
Naja.
Ich glaube, das dauert noch ein paar Monate, oder?
Aber es wird mal Zeit für Teil 2, würde ich sagen
Wobei, es gab sogar schon mal Teil 2
Ah, witzig, ja
Dass sich die Leute da noch dran erinnern
Leute, wer von euch erinnert sich noch an das Schneestells-Video?
Diesen Winter 5 Meter Schnee
Ich weiß, by the way, bis heute nicht, warum das Video 2 Millionen Aufrufe hat
Das Schneestellziel.
Kein Pflaster Schimmer, ey.
Das habe ich damals auch nicht gecheckt.
Das ist auf der Startseite gelandet.
Ein Video, wo ich mit dem Handy durch meinen Garten laufe
und random irgendwelche Sachen filme.
Banger Video.
Die Leute haben damals in die Kommentare geschrieben,
sie haben sich das ganze Video angeguckt,
weil sie dachten,
jetzt kommt noch irgendwann der Jumpscare.
Der kam halt nie.
Die haben gedacht, gleich passiert was,
gleich passiert was bei der ard social media vertreter ist erzählt das schon
als arbeitszeitbetrug aber hier auf twitch chillt mit dem offiziellen
account also nicht dass ich ein problem damit hätte ja das ist damals zeit
perfekt
das machen wir zwangs geht gezwungenermaßen ja aber vielleicht gibt
es ja dieses diesen winter ordentlich schnee oder wirf durch den schnee
stellst. Okay, Leute, also das hier funzt nicht.
Es ist egal, was ich mache.
Sobald ich
Riden will auf den USB-Stick, ist es kaputt.
Okay, so.
Das ist halt ziemlich kacke.
Wir machen
jetzt hier nochmal Reset.
Und dann...
Wie ging das
jetzt?
Ich weiß.
Reset.
Reset, wait.
dick. So, das machen wir jetzt
und hoffen einfach mal,
das liegt nur an
der Container-Geschichte,
dass es nicht richtig funktioniert.
So, jetzt mach ich den USB-Stick mal raus.
Tum-tum, tum-tum.
Und wieder an.
Oh, schauen wir mal. Ja, ja, connected.
Ah, ne, jetzt muss ich wieder detachen.
Not found.
Ja, das liegt daran, weil...
It must be no device.
Das liegt daran...
Hast du Urlaub?
Nee, ich hab montags immer frei.
Das liegt daran, weil wir...
das unbinden müssen.
Hä?
No Device. Warum ist denn jetzt schon wieder No Device?
Was ist das jetzt hier?
Def
Bus
LSUSB
Uptinstall
Äh
Was muss man dafür installieren?
USB-Utils oder sowas bestimmt.
Ja, wisst ihr?
USB-Utils.
Evil Hook, danke schön für den Sub.
Also da ist der Stick.
Penden tut der eh nicht.
Das liegt doch jetzt bestimmt an irgendeinem Containermist, oder?
Wann es endlich wieder Sellout gibt?
Ich muss erstmal die Rechnung für die letzten Sellout
noch einreichen.
Gibt es zwei Container?
Nee, wo sollen die herkommen?
Also wir haben doch immer noch das Richtige hier.
0 FCF
Es gibt nicht zwei Container.
Der hat ja das
Hausdateisystem gemountet.
Also das wüsste ich
jetzt nicht, warum das nicht funktionieren
sollte.
Er ist ja auch da, der USB-Stick.
Ist das eine Berechtigungsgeschichte?
Does not recover from USB reconnect.
Ja geil.
Okay, es ist ein Container-Bug anscheinend.
Das ist irgendein Container-Bug.
Was aber ziemlich reudig ist.
Vielleicht ist da noch ein Docker-Problem.
USB-Path-Thru, ja.
Not...
Was?
Use the...
plus...
minus...
device...
Z-Group-Rule...
What the fuck?
Okay, das ist ein Container-Bug.
Das leckt am Container.
Okay, also das heißt, im Endeffekt
gehen wir mal hier raus, machen den Scheiß nochmal zu.
Close and stop, bam.
Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt
noch irgendwie sowas hier.
Die weiß
Aber wir haben doch einen Privileged Container.
Da darf doch eh schon alles, dachte ich.
Oder nicht?
Moment.
So.
Moin.
So, Privileged.
Oh ja.
Delete.
Okay, das war vielleicht keine so schlaue Idee
Ey, Condef
Dolent
Was?
Okay, das mag er nicht
Fail to start, warum?
Warum?
Weil die weiß, Seacroop rule
Mag er nicht.
Das ist Potman.
Docker.
Was ist das hier überhaupt?
Device C-Group Rule.
Was soll das überhaupt bedeuten?
Also was hat er da für...
Also...
Was ist das überhaupt?
Dev-Container Jason.
Ja, das haben wir doch.
Okay, anscheinend ist der so clever
Oder soll ich das besser so machen?
Weil aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Ne, ne, ne, das muss doch
Das muss doch
Okay, keine Ahnung, ich probier's mal
Okay
Anscheinend.
Ist das die bessere Variante?
Aber ich habe wirklich kein...
Was macht...
Da war ein Ding hier hinten.
Ne, das war komplett gequotet vorhin.
Mage. Okay, Character Device.
Also ein zeichenorientiertes Gerät.
Major Device Number.
Warte mal.
USB-Geräte?
Okay, es ist irgendeine USB-Geräte-Magic.
By the way, falls die ARD noch da ist.
Wie kommt die gerade jetzt random in den Channel eigentlich?
Also, was hat euch hergeführt?
Wahrscheinlich schon wieder weg.
So, Go-App.
Computerclub wiederbeleben.
Oh, da war ich dabei.
Werbung? Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht.
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt wieder funktioniert.
Hä?
Go? Was?
Achso, ja ich bin ja auch dumm, Alter.
Warum wirst du nicht VTuber?
Das habe ich mir tatsächlich schon mal überlegt.
So blöd das klingt, das habe ich mir schon mal überlegt.
Ich habe aber keinen gefunden, der einen gescheiten Keks-Avatar machen kann.
ich fände es lustig
ach so jetzt ist es komplett geclosed das ist auch dumm
Und wie kann ich mich denn jetzt reconnecten hier?
Gateway?
Ist das da noch drin?
Dev-Containers?
Ne.
Gott.
Alter.
Das ist heute wieder kompliziert.
Oland.
Alter, das ist heute wieder kompliziert.
Das ist eigentlich ein Pepo-Avatar.
Bestimmt, bestimmt.
Aber damit sich das für VTube Sachen eignet, brauchst du halt was, was angepasst wird, dass es animiert werden kann.
Und das ist gar nicht so easy.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich sowas mit AI machen will.
Was benutzt du für eine Oberfläche? KDE? Ja, das ist KDE.
KDE, wie die coolen Leute sagen.
Aber ich bin auch Team KDE.
Er muss ja nicht alles übertrieben cool aussprechen.
Warum hat er das jetzt nicht geöffnet?
Alter, was ist hier kaputt?
Hallo?
Open?
Okay, dann open ich jetzt das hier.
Ach, das geht.
Das geht.
Aber
Go-App-Open geht nicht.
Nö.
Ja, hat er keinen Bock.
Will er nicht.
Juckt ihn nicht.
Aber App Open geht
Hä?
Hast du die Ukrainerin mal erreicht?
Ich hab das nie direkt mit der gemacht
Wegen den Emotes
Hab ich immer über eine Zwischenstation gemacht
Und haben wir noch nicht
Weiter angefragt
Sag mal, wollen die mich komplett verarschen?
Gerade
Warum funsten das alles nicht?
Ach, jetzt geht's.
Niri, ja, Niri hab ich schon ausprobiert.
Das fand ich gar nicht so blöd.
Fand ich eigentlich echt ganz gut.
Kann mir mal erklären, was der hier jetzt eigentlich für Probleme hat.
Was juckt ihn denn hier?
Lock Fatal gibt's nicht.
Weil Lock nicht importiert ist.
Natürlich ist Lock importiert. Ich seh's da doch.
Was ist das hier für komisches Rumgebagge?
Was ist das hier los?
Ich mach das nochmal alles zu.
Ich hab Close and Keep Running gemacht.
Das wollte ich nicht.
Kann das jetzt vielleicht einfach mal wieder funktionieren,
damit ich weitermachen kann?
Oh, Pragy, geht das jetzt vielleicht?
Wir haben sogar einen Stream gemacht, wo wir Niri eingerichtet haben.
Aber ich habe da nicht weiter gemacht, weil ich bin eigentlich mit dem Setup recht glücklich.
Und ich weiß das mittlerweile an KDE zu schätzen, dass man bei KDE halt nichts wirklich machen muss.
Sag mal, was hat meine IDE gerade für Schmerzen?
Kann mir das irgendjemand mal sinnvoll erklären?
Angeblich gibt es Lock Fatal nicht.
Natürlich gibt es das.
Pseudo Go Run.
Ach so, muss er den Kram nochmal...
Go Run.
a lip usb 1.0 okay abt sudo abt install lip usb minus 1.0
packets decrease oder war es 1.0 minus 0 minus def das hat das total hängen gebliebenen namen
Ja
Okay, Bad Access, alles in Ordnung
Es funzt, Leute
Es geht wieder
Heartbeat 71
Okay, mal kurz
Mal kurz chillen
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Okay, Funst.
Okay, mal gucken, ob das jetzt noch weiter funktioniert.
Respected. Was ist da dran?
Warum ist das so broken?
End plus not found.
Expected.
What?
Okay, kann sich meine Idee
vielleicht mal wieder einkriegen
und selbst fixen?
Feldzustand an Plus-Scan.
Okay.
Reset-Device
funktioniert ja anscheinend.
Okay, kann das sein,
dass es bei dem Reset
Ich hab ne Idee.
Kann das sein, dass es bei dem Reset
irgendwie wieder
Das ist in der Tat aber echt unschön, dass man das nicht neu starten kann.
Aber vorher, ich muss mal meine IDE fixen.
Was hat das denn für Probleme, Alter?
Was will das denn?
Warum meint er Fatal Unresolved Reference?
What the fuck? Natürlich gibt es das. Sogar, witzigerweise, sogar Autocomplete sagt, dass es das gibt.
Okay, Jet Brains, whatever. Keine Ahnung, Alter.
Reset, wait. Wir machen, okay, wir machen nochmal was anderes. Time, sleep.
Eine Sekunde mal
Seconds.
Das geht nicht.
Und mal N plus USB.
Achso, das ist hier. Das ist dieses dumme.
Reset.
Failed.
Das machen wir so.
Okay.
Wir warten eine Sekunde und dann sagen wir wirklich nochmal Error.
Weil das eigentlich egal sein müsste.
Okay, fail to start and plus scan expected.
Was zum Teufel soll das denn jetzt schon wieder bedeuten?
Also diese Libraries sind alle ziemlich eklig
Zu benutzen
Ja okay
Wo ist denn das Chat-GPT
Was mir vorhin das Ding ausgespuckt hat
Das hab ich nicht mehr
Bin ja auch nicht eingeloggt
Ah doch hier
War das noch das Go-Ding?
Wir können auch mal...
Was könnte jetzt das Problem sein?
Fail to start.
Was will mir das sagen?
Mach ich das vielleicht falsch rum?
Muss ich vielleicht sagen.
Aber früher resetten kann ich ja nur wirklich nicht.
Also der hat echt richtig Probleme.
Und das liegt jetzt aber auch nicht mehr am Device oder an dem Container.
Das ist irgendwie so ein...
Keine Ahnung.
Wie?
Okay, wir schließen mal aus.
Wir schließen mal aus, dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise
ihr Problem ist von
mir, okay? Von dem Container.
Wir sagen jetzt einfach Go, Run.
Geht nicht, ja, Sudo.
Okay, das ist kein Container-Problem.
Wir machen den Stick nochmal raus und wieder rein.
Busy.
Okay, das liegt jetzt daran, weil er diesen komischen Treiber geladen hat.
Unbind.
Okay.
Kunst. Okay. Gut.
Abbrechen.
Okay. Sobald es einmal war, sobald es einmal gelesen hat,
packt er ab damit.
Wir müssen mal in das Beispiel, wir müssen mal in das Scan-Beispiel,
ich trage den Sensor gerade, ja,
wir müssen mal das Scan-Beispiel uns von der Python-Library angucken,
weil dort ging es ja guck mal das ist eine gute idee es kann man ausprobieren hier app uv wie ist
das ding wie das wird sein uv run open and scan ja ja so doch nicht ich bin
verwirrt dass das ging nur so ne 11 11 so und jetzt uv run open and scan
No such file or directory haben wir jetzt.
Geht doch.
Also zumindest
der
Scanner,
der Python-Scanner
...
Okay, das folgt aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht.
Das macht aber nichts.
Also das Go-Programm ist auf jeden Fall kaputt.
Also Container entwickeln ist echt ein bisschen eklig, wenn du mit Device eine Hand haben musst.
No Device.
Wo ist der denn jetzt, das Device?
Also das hier findet das, das ist überhaupt kein Problem damit.
Hier oben bin ich in dem Container, hier unten nicht.
Die Weiß-O-Resource-Busy.
Ah ja, okay, weil Unbind.
Okay, das ist mit.
Ich teste das jetzt hier unten.
Das ist mir zu dumm. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr, die Containersachen zu debuggen.
Okay, aber
sag mal so, das Go-Ding geht
immer kaputt.
Wir müssen mal in dieses Python-Example
gucken, weil das hier...
Weil das funzt immer.
Guck, das funzt immer.
dieses Open-End-Scan,
das Funst.
Danach muss ich immer das Device
entfernen.
Und dann,
wenn ich Glück habe,
machen wir es mal so,
und dann, wenn ich Glück habe,
geht das wieder.
Hier oben geht es
prinzipiell gar nicht mehr. Juckt mich nicht.
Machen wir es einfach mal ein bisschen kleiner.
So, und das
geht dann immer, nachdem es einmal
resetet wurde.
Und ich das unbindet habe.
Oh, das ist
schon echt...
Ziemlich eklig.
Vielleicht, weil noch ein Handle auf dem Device liegt.
Das kann sein, aber was ich merkwürdig
finde ist, guck mal.
Der kann das Device
ja öffnen und lesen,
aber
dann kackt er ab.
Und was die Python Library macht, ist,
die resettet
einmal dieses komplette USB-Device.
Also ich muss das komplette USB-Device
resetten. Also hier USB
gibt es halt nicht.
Ja, leider, leider
Okay, ich hab ne Big
Brain Idee
Ich hab ne Big
Wir verwenden noch
Go USB
Reset oder so
Das kriegen wir hin
das kriegen wir hin genau genau das also wir müssen gucken doch doch doch doch ich habe
nicht habe eine idee also es liegt daran wir müssen jetzt erstmal github openend wir müssen
uns mal das beispiel angucken make no mistakes no mist no mistakes aloud examples ist da der
der scan drin scan scanner
ok die weißes scanner und updates der moment moment der macht ja kein
Wo könnte...
Könnten die das versteckt haben?
Main?
Init?
Ah, Argument Parser.
Scan.
Müssen gucken, was sie machen.
Ja, Pip, Open, End.
Jetzt mal gucken, ob wir überhaupt die richtige Library haben, okay?
Man weiß ja nie.
Tegel und Tunafisch.
Gibt es hier einen Link zum GitHub-Depot?
Gibt es, Chat, ihr kennt euch mit Preisen, geht uns besser aus.
Gibt es da irgendwie Links zu GitHub?
Dass man, also weiß, wo das hier ist?
Ah, hier.
Hier.
TG Open End.
Ja, okay.
So, wir klonen uns das mal.
Wir müssen nämlich gucken, was das macht.
Epos, Git, Clone.
Wir müssen gucken, was...
Weil die resetten das USB-Ding irgendwie.
Das müssen wir auch machen.
Wir können auch einfach die Python Library verwenden
Und auf Go scheißen, aber
Wenn wir einfach was wollen, was funktioniert
Chat
Da kann ich es einfach über Bluetooth machen, ja
Wir geben
Leute, wir geben Opus mal was zu tun
In der Zwischenzeit
wir geben Opus mal kurz was zu tun
ähm
hi
nein nein nicht Mistral
WTF äh Claude
und zwar
Opus 5 wollen wir haben
ähm
ich will
von einem
N plus Stick
mein Heartbeat auslesen.
Ich will mit
einem Endplus mein Heartbeat auslesen.
Benutze
GoUSB
um darauf zuzugreifen.
So, bam.
Was nimmst du? Ich habe so einen Stick.
Ich habe hier so einen
DIN-Stream
Endplus
So, hier so ein kleines Putzding hab ich.
Oh ja.
Beste.
DevSetAutoAttach True
Kernel, Treiber, USB Serial
Das klingt doch schon mal ganz gut
Das ist auch noch irgendwie übersichtlich, oder?
Direkt über USB
Oh, oh, oh, oh, shit
Okay, es wird, es wird
Gut, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben
Aber bevor, ganz ehrlich, Leute
Bevor wir uns ewig mit irgendwelchen kaputten Libraries und Sachen rumschlagen, ne?
Warum machen wir nicht einfach selbst was?
Oder?
Guck mal, ob ich noch irgendwas sehe.
So, jetzt müssen wir nochmal gucken.
Also, ich wollte herauskriegen, wie man dieses Python-Ding, das das macht.
Also, GoUSB, da haben wir doch hier schon mal ein schönes Beispiel gehabt.
GoUSB?
Device?
Ja, ja.
Set Auto Attach
Device.
Ja gut, das Problem ist,
das rückt das hier nicht raus.
Was hier ist.
Ah,
Moment mal.
Ah.
Aber man hat da keinen Zugriff
drauf. Das ist halt kacke.
Das ist halt kacke.
Guck, der gibt zurück einen Driver, also quasi den USB-Stick.
Das Dumme ist nur, dass wir keinen Zugriff drauf haben, weil in Go ist es so,
alles was klein geschrieben ist hier in so einem Struct, ist private.
Oder war das bei Python? Ne, ne, ne.
Bei Python ist es so, was mit einem Underscore ist, ist private, gell?
Oder zumindest, zumindest
Man sollte es nicht benutzen
So, ich glaube zugreifen kann man trotzdem drauf
Das ist natürlich
Das ist natürlich sehr unpraktisch
Weil
Sonst könnten wir halt sagen
Auto-Attach
Aber das können wir doch auch so machen
Okay Leute, ich hab ne Idee
Ich hab ne Idee
Wir resetten den Kram
Einmal bevor der andere
Treiber drauf zugreift
Das machen wir
Das müsste doch ausreichen
Das müsste doch eigentlich reichen
Also wir sagen jetzt hier
Was müssen wir machen hier
ETX
Okay okay das probieren wir
Also bevor wir diesen ganzen Campel machen
Go USB
Context
Ja was weiß ich
USB CTX
Das müssen wir dann noch ein bisschen hübscher
Müssten voneinander trennen
Weil ansonsten blickt es ja nicht mehr durch
So USB CTX
So dann sagen wir
CTX Open Device
CTX Open
Wenn ich das jetzt so richtig schreiben könnte
Open device with fit
Fit und Pit
Also quasi so
Genauso wie das hier
Ja
So, dann müssen wir noch irgendwie Error handeln
Device
Oh, fuck, jetzt habe ich es gelöscht
Def
Ja, genau sowas in der Richtung.
Def.
Wenn Error, dann
Log Fatal.
Wir machen auch so, ist scheiß drauf.
Ja, Twitch-Formel mit den Katzen,
wir sowas vergessen. So, und dann müssen
wir sagen, Def.
Def set auto
attach.
Was passiert denn,
wenn ich einfach so sage, Death Close.
Reicht das schon?
So.
Wir sind bei der Go-App.
Go Run.
USB-Stick not found.
Äh, what? Warum?
Ich habe irgendwas verkehrt gemacht.
Ich bin zu dumm dafür.
New Context habe ich doch.
Ah, New Context.
Okay, okay.
Okay, immer noch das gleiche Problem.
Immer noch das gleiche Problem.
Also Death Close reicht nicht.
Gibt es denn sowas wie Death Reset?
Das gibt es.
Meine Güte, ey.
Go Error Handling.
Ich will ja einfach nur, dass das Ding jetzt wieder funzt.
Error gleich.
Dann sleepen wir nochmal kurz hier.
Zack.
Nee, vorher können wir ja nicht resetten.
Wir brauchen ja dieses Device-Handle.
Ha!
Guck mal da.
Ja, guck mal da.
Und schon funzt's.
Fuck!
Okay, es funktioniert nur jedes zweite Mal.
What?
Chad?
Warum?
Okay, okay, okay, okay
Ganz easy, weil
Wir machen einfach diesen Scheiß hier
Ja
Das machen wir einfach raus, okay
Weil wen juckt das
Wir müssen es ja nicht zweimal resetten
Okay
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Müssen wir es doch zweimal resetten
Chat, ich blicke nicht mehr durch, Alter.
Warum?
Eindeutig Errorless Development.
Super Errorless ist das hier.
Also wir haben es auf jeden Fall
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
schon ein wenig gefixt.
Weil...
Weil guckt mal, jedes zweite Mal
funktioniert es ja.
Seht ihr das?
Jedes zweite Mal geht es.
Okay, kann das sein?
Kann das sein? Einfach nur mal so.
Komm, warte ich vielleicht nicht lang genug.
Einfach, wenn es nicht geht,
einfach immer sleepen.
Das klappt öfters, als man denkt.
Und danach nur Reboot. Fuck, das reicht nicht.
Okay, okay, okay.
Sleep ich hier nicht lang genug danach?
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mache?
Du glaubst nicht, dass die Anordnung korrekt ist?
Das kann schon sein.
Fucking shit, Alter.
Warum geht das nur jedes zweite Mal?
Okay, Next Tag.
Was meinst du, was verkehrt rum ist?
Ich meine, wir machen...
Wir holen uns den USB-Kontext.
Dann...
Dann resetten wir das.
Ach so.
Warte mal.
Moment.
Ja, ne, doch. Ist doch richtig.
Dann resetten wir das und closen wir das.
Sollte ich vielleicht nach dem Closen auch nochmal warten?
Warten wir einfach sinnlos neun Sekunden.
Fuck!
Okay, also das
ist schon einmal nicht
Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Also was ich
auf jeden Fall jetzt mal mitnehmen kann
von der ganzen Geschichte ist,
vielleicht sollte ich es einfach mal nicht closen
und gucken, was dann passiert.
Das ist jetzt einfach random.
Einfach random irgendwelche Dinge ausprobieren.
Okay, shit.
Aber ich sollte es auf jeden Fall
closen, bevor ich das hier wieder öffne.
KI erklären lassen,
was der Code tut.
Ja, vielleicht.
Also schön ist es halt wirklich nicht schön.
Es ist so hässlich.
Aber was ich merkwürdig finde ist,
welches...
Also guck mal.
Hier, wenn ich das hier weg mache,
das hier alleine reicht nicht.
Das hier alleine reicht nicht.
Vom Reset her.
So, seht ihr?
Es ist immer der gleiche Fehler.
Das heißt, wir brauchen
Dieses Reset hier oben.
Aber witzigerweise,
dieses Reset hier oben.
Das hier, ne?
Das reicht auch wiederum nicht.
Wir brauchen beides.
Guck.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Jetzt scannt er Hard-Rate-Sensors und macht gar nichts mehr
Okay, der braucht einfach ein bisschen nach dem Reset
Aber der Reset unten
Der Reset unten muss auch sein
Weil sonst geht das gar nicht
Also der hier
Der hier muss auf jeden Fall sein
Sonst geht er gar nicht
Ja
Wisst ihr was ich glaube
Das liegt nicht einfach daran weil es jedes zweite Mal geht
Wenn es jedes zweite Mal
Die Zeit ist dann einfach abgelaufen dazwischen
Also
Also ich meine ich könnte ja
Ansonsten könnte ich ja einfach hier sagen
For
For range
äh, ne, warte mal, vor, wie geht das hier?
Vor
i in
kleiner 2, so, könnte ich
einfach diesen ganzen Krempel
in eine Schleife packen
und dann
macht er das zweimal.
Guck.
Das bringt's nicht.
Und jetzt brech ich mal ab.
Ich brech jetzt mal ab.
Und jetzt warte ich mal.
Jetzt warte ich mal kurz, bevor ich nochmal neu starte.
Okay?
Jetzt warten wir mal.
Und jetzt machen wir's nochmal.
Ey, was ist das?
Ich check's net.
Das ist mir zu kompliziert, Alter.
Okay, wir müssen uns
den Code weiter angucken.
Releasen wir das Device
bei Ctrl-C? Ja.
Machen wir.
Bei Ctrl-C
wird
das da gemacht.
Cancel.
Und was macht Cancel?
Ne, warte mal.
Moment.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Stick hier.
Da machen wir das.
Der Stick wird immer closed.
Hier gibt es ja kein close.
Hier, wir machen immer ein Stick close, bevor das Programm sich beendet.
Immer.
Okay, wir müssen uns das anders angucken.
Also, Open End.
Open End habe ich geklont.
So, was machen die hier bei dem?
Wir können aber auch nochmal hier gucken, was das Ding hier treibt.
Also, das...
Set... Was macht das hier?
Set...
Auto Detach.
Was genau macht das?
Also, diesen Mist mit der Schleife, ne?
Das machen wir mal wieder weg.
Okay, noch ein Test.
Ein Test, Leute. Ein Test.
Dreimal. Dreimal resetten. Bam.
Gucken, ob das jetzt geht.
Error of Pre-Programming, Leute.
Ich sag's euch.
Okay, gut.
Next.
Okay, daran liegt es nicht.
Daran liegt es nicht.
Wird Stick Lost aufgerufen, wenn du Ctrl-C machst?
Ja.
Guck hier.
Defer.
Defer heißt, egal was passiert,
bevor du aus diesem Block rausgehst,
das da aufrufen.
Okay, also das mit der Schleife ist schon mal
nicht so geil.
Das ist von uns nett.
Wir brauchen aber,
witzigerweise, wir brauchen
beide Resets, sonst geht das nicht.
Hat Reset
vielleicht Argumente irgendwie?
Ne.
Nur mal, dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Dieses Reset hier
ist ein Reset
von der
AND-Plus-Config.
Ne?
Und dieses Reset
hier ist ein Reset
des USB-Devices.
also was haben wir sonst noch hier def out set out to the touch
macht was
set out to the touch enables the same automatic kornel treiber die touch
man when auto die touch is an abel goers will automatisch die texte
kölner treiber ohne interface and reattachend wenn releasing der interface
ok ja wohl perfekt
alter macht meine idee da wieder
bestes error handling aller zeiten
Ah, ich hab ne Idee.
Chat, ich hab ne Idee.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Irgendjemand meinte doch...
Die Fert-Functions
does not run.
Ihr meintet doch, die Reihenfolge ist falsch.
Vielleicht sollten wir...
Vielleicht sollten wir tatsächlich
einen Defer-Block noch machen.
Defer? Kann man das?
Kann man da einen Block machen? Geht das?
Nee, oder?
Okay, Moment.
Punk. Reset. Device.
Okay, sonst ist es eh ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Reset Device.
Oh.
Soll ich das jetzt noch...
Okay.
So. Reset Device.
Und dann sagen wir noch
Differ Reset Device.
Also quasi, wir resetten noch mal.
Wir resetten noch mal,
wenn der fertig ist.
Und wir machen jetzt hier noch mal ein Print oben drüber.
FMT Printen.
Reset. So, einfach, dass wir es wissen.
Reset.
Scanning device.
Zack. Reset.
Okay. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ach, fuck.
Alter.
Es ist egal, wo wir reseten.
Es funzt einfach nicht.
Aber was ist der Sinn?
Warum müssen wir das immer zweimal starten?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Also wir müssen auf jeden Fall resetten am Anfang.
Da führt kein Weg dran vorbei.
Okay, noch mal was anderes.
Wir müssen es immer zweimal starten.
Weshalb auch immer.
Dann machen wir doch einfach...
Dann machen wir das doch einfach mehrfach.
Oh, shit.
Oh, jetzt hab ich's, jetzt hab ich's...
Jetzt hab ich's gebraked, Alter.
Die Fährstick-Close.
Warum immer zweimal? Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht resette der nicht fertig?
Ich meine, der macht nach dem Reset immerhin noch ein Sleep.
Wir können auch mal hier bis unten hin pappen.
Aber wenn ich sage, stick close, ist doch eigentlich alles okay.
Was muss ich denn sonst noch closen?
Nix, oder?
Bam.
Nochmal Reset Device.
Ich resette einfach so, bis es geht.
Oh, fuck.
Ne, Moment.
Reset device.
Wir resetten einfach.
Reset to win, Leute.
Ah, shit.
Okay, Chat, wir müssen es verstehen.
Es hat keinen Sinn.
Es hat keinen Sinn, was wir hier machen.
Oh, jetzt habe ich es komplett kaputt gemacht.
Oh, guck mal.
Jetzt hat er Attached wieder als Serial Device.
Unbind.
Okay, dann doch jetzt nochmal.
Ah, das ist, das ist.
Ich verstehe, ich verstehe.
Das ist, weil wir Auto Attached jetzt drin haben.
Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall nicht das Problem.
Ist das überhaupt ein Problem?
Einfach nur, weil es drin steht, oder was?
Aber das könnte wirklich das Problem sein, dass es danach wieder da ist.
Wo kommt denn das jetzt so vor allem mal her?
Das ist hier dieses ganze Gedöns, was ich hier drinnen mache.
Das ist einfach zu viel.
Das ist zu viel Resette.
Das kackt's ab.
Okay, gut.
Also hat keinen Sinn. Wir müssen es verstehen,
was hier passiert. Dann gucken wir doch mal,
was machen die hier denn in dieser Scan-Demo?
Nach was muss ich denn jetzt hier suchen?
Ich suche nach einem Command-Line-Interface.
Vielleicht easy?
Maybe?
Init?
Chat, nach was würdet ihr suchen,
wenn ihr in Python Command-Line-Interface
suchen würdet.
Grab. Scan machen wir mal.
Okay, gibt's ja nicht so viel.
Sub-Parsers-Scan.
Das ist es.
Ich sag's euch, das ist es.
Also was macht er hier?
Run
Ja das ist
Kann man hier filtern
Und dann macht er was
woran weiß man jetzt was er startet argument arguments hier funk run
auto scanner ach hier ok auto scanner also dass das ist das was hier passiert also der
sagt,
Set Network Key. Okay, passt. Scanner.
Found.
Da sieht man jetzt nicht genau, was er macht.
Da müssen wir gucken, was im Scanner
drin steht.
Device is found.
If auto create.
Okay, ich weiß
nicht was das jetzt macht auf welches device bezieht sich denn jetzt ist das jetzt usb
also ist ja nicht was macht aber wir müssen auf jeden fall wir müssen auf jeden fall in scanner
gucken scanner da ist es doch die weiße scanner da macht der usb gedöns hier drinnen geht auch
übersichtlich ist auch übersichtlich also und data juckt uns erstmal nicht
safe juckt uns auch nicht und frauen auch nicht static messe das war's wo
macht er denn das ganze usb gedöns
macht er das usb gedöns
Hier, hä?
Device ID, Device Type.
Ne, das ist schon End Plus.
Das ist nicht mehr USB.
OMG, Alter.
Ist das kompliziert.
Also, was wir jetzt rausgekriegt haben,
wir müssen auf jeden Fall,
damit das immerhin, ne?
Damit das immerhin
jedes zweite Mal funktioniert.
Damit das jedes zweite Mal
funktioniert,
müssen wir
doppelt resetten.
Aber dann
punzt es auch.
Wisst ihr was ich merkwürdig finde?
Wenn es funktioniert
Dann resetet er doppelt
Guck hier
Und er
disconnected dann auch wieder.
Macht er vielleicht irgendwas
nicht,
wenn das hier Fail to Start ist?
Oh, er sollte ja gar nicht Fail to Start
machen, ne?
Okay.
Wisst ihr was? Wir stellen uns einfach mal dumm.
Warum funktioniert das nur jedes zweite Mal?
Ein USB-Reconnect-Reset-Problem.
Ja, so schlau war ich auch schon.
Du machst ein USB-Reset mit einem separat erzeugten Kontext.
Schließt das Device und öffnet es.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Okay, das Chat-GPT hat auch keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß, dass ich noch ein Reset mache.
Die weiß Reset komplett entfernen.
Nein, nein, nein.
USB-CTX-Close fehlt.
USB-CTX-Close.
Äh, ups.
Das könnte natürlich durchaus
sinnvoll sein.
Was ist jetzt für ein Problem?
Unhandled Error.
What?
Ist das, Chad, ist das
the go away, das so zu machen?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, meine Idee
hier einfach, das ist the go away.
das zu machen.
Oh, Chat, guck mal.
Hier ging's, dann ist es abgekackt
und jetzt geht's wieder.
Vielleicht ist es doch eine Sache von
man muss einfach eine Weile warten.
Fuck, alter!
Warum geht das nicht?
Okay, jetzt machen wir wirklich was.
So.
Ich brech jetzt ab und ich mach jetzt nix.
Okay?
Die Musik passt doch gut.
Passt doch richtig gut.
Ich mach jetzt einfach mal gar nix.
Ich mach jetzt hier 5 Sekunden, 10 Sekunden irgendwie nix.
Okay, Chad gibt mir da auch keinen Blassenschimmer, was da das Problem ist.
Okay, jetzt läuft es wieder, findet aber nichts.
Das ist echt ätzend, Chad. Wisst ihr das?
dass das so
so unzuverlässig
funktioniert.
Ich kann ja
Clouding-Coaching... Ja!
Mein Problem ist,
mein Copy-Paste-Fonts nicht richtig.
Ich muss... Okay, doch, das kann ich
machen.
Ja, neue Unterhaltung.
Mit
Denkmodelle.
Opus, können wir gleich machen
Äh
Ja, ich meine, ich könnte sagen
Oh
Oh nein, man kann nicht scrollen hier drin
Gescheit
Und Denkmodelle Opus
Wir fragen, wir fragen wirklich
Ich hab echt kein Schimmer, was das ist.
Müssen uns das Vibe callen.
Jetzt kackt er wieder ab gleich.
Hä? Chat, Chat!
Was jetzt?
Alter, das ist total unzuverlässig.
klappt meistens nur jedes zweite mal ansonsten fehler
ich kann den fehler nicht kopieren
Run.
Pseudo-Go-Run.
Ja.
Okay, Opus.
Let's go.
Das sieht nach einem Timing-Problem aus
Ja, aber ich hab das schon doppelt und dreifach gemacht
Ich hab da gesleept und alles
Okay, also
Das ist ein klassisches Problem
Alter, laber halt rum, du dummes Model, Alter
Classic
Das ist ein klassisches Problem mit End-Plus-Sticks
Nach der Frisette liegen noch alte, ungelesene Nachrichten
end point baffert sticks was die beides bedeuten die start up notification die das dick nach einem
reset schickt eine broadcast nachricht von einem sensor du bekommst also eine podcast nachricht aus
einer vorherigen session der stick hat noch kanäle offen weil dein programm beim letzten mal nicht
sauber close channel reset system gemacht hat oder gekillt wurde ja aber wie mache ich close
Channel. Das ist ja das Ding.
Okay.
Ofer leeren Train vor dem Reset.
Nach dem Reset auf
0xf warten,
statt es sofort zu verwerfen.
What?
Def unassigned Channel.
Ach so.
Moment.
Ja, aber der Channel ist doch egal,
ob ich den Channel schließe oder nicht.
Aber Reset System gibt es gar nicht.
Das labert einfach nur hier.
Def.
Reset System. Das gibt es überhaupt nicht.
Das ist einfach nur halluxinierter Krampel.
Aber Anne sein Channel
Das finde ich schon mal gut
Aber das gibt es hier auch nicht
Oh man, das ist das falsche
Das ist das falsche Dev
Ah, das Dev, Braumer
Dev, Dev
Die weiß
Wo ist es?
Device reset
Moment
Das hab ich ja da oben schon gemacht
Ja das andere
Das andere Zeug gibt es nicht
Die Methoden gibt es halt alle nicht
Was der sich da
Zurecht
Zurecht macht
Aber
ich habe eine Idee, was wir machen können.
Das wird das wahrscheinlich fixen,
denke ich mal.
Okay, super krasse Magic-Geschichte.
Ein Hinweis noch zu deinem bestehenden Code.
Log Fatal in der Defer Function
und nach dem Open ist unschön.
Lockfettle ruft OSX hier auf, wodurch alle anderen
Differs über... Ach ja.
Ach hier.
Ja.
Okay.
Vielleicht brauchen wir das. Vielleicht brauchen wir das ja gar nicht.
Ich hab ne Idee. Wart mal. Ich lass mal
dieses Reset Device hier mal komplett weg.
Dann haben wir wieder das alte Problem,
dass das nicht funzt.
So. Aber jetzt.
Aber jetzt.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt...
Was? Expected 40?
Gott, 60?
Expected 6F? Gott, 40?
Expected 40?
Gott, 6F?
What?
Okay, also, was wir
vielleicht machen könnten, ist,
der Vorschlag von ChatGPT
war ja wirklich nicht so übel.
Also als erstes, wir könnten das mal versuchen mehrfach zu starten.
Annen, dann darf ich aber nicht Log Fatal machen.
Die Messages zu drainen.
Das war ja schon mal keine dumme Idee.
Notify?
Was passiert denn jetzt?
Cancel?
Und beim Cancel?
Ja gut, dann
Ja diese ganzen Funktionen, die er da aufgezählt hat
Die gibt es ja gar nicht
Also was ich gerade sagen wollte ist
Wir können das ja mehrfach starten
Im Endeffekt, ja
Kann er hier sagen, keine Ahnung
Da, bla bla bla bla bla, so
Irgendwie, und dann starten
So in der Hoffnung, dass es dann halt geht
Ach, das
Das trägt wohl dazu bei, dass es dann manchmal
Funktioniert, geil
Okay, das sorgt auch dafür
Dass es hier das zweite Mal geht
Also ich glaube
ChatGPT
Hat da einen Punkt
Ja ich glaube
ChatGPT hat da echt einen Punkt
Da sind noch Messages drin
Das Ding ist nur
Wie können da noch Messages drin sein
Wenn ich ein USB Reset mache
Und gerade auch, wenn ich hier einen Reset mache, wie können da noch Messages da drin sein?
Können wir... Okay, okay, mal andere Idee.
Können wir das hier nicht vorher machen?
Und dann...
Ja.
Genau, jetzt kackt es ab oder jetzt geht es oder was auch immer.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Hä?
Okay, jetzt blicke ich gar nicht mehr durch
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es damit irgendwas zu tun hat
Jetzt funktioniert es aber gar nicht mehr, ne?
Jetzt ist es komplett procken
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, das Ding fängt dann halt ganz normal an
Oh mein Gott, das macht mich fertig.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das so ein Akt ist.
Also man muss das anscheinend so rum machen.
Weil ich habe nach einer Möglichkeit gesucht.
Ich habe nach einer Möglichkeit gesucht,
hier einfach ein paar sinnlose Bytes von dem Stick zu lesen.
Okay, jetzt haben wir den Stick komplett kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt brauchen wir wieder ein Reset-Device.
Chat, jetzt ist es komplett kaputt wieder.
Jetzt musst du den USB-Stick reinstecken und rausziehen.
Ich dreh echt am Rad mit diesem Problem.
USB.
Unbind.
Einfach ein USB haben mit Relay.
Ja, genau.
Hard Reset.
Also dieses Reset Device
können wir da schon drinnen lassen.
dann sorgt immerhin dafür, dass es hier das zweite Mal geht.
USB resetten, kurz warten, Interface neu öffnen, ja mach ich, das mach ich doch so.
Der macht Auto-Detach weiterhin.
Okay.
Dann macht er USB-Level-Reset.
Also im Prinzip alles so weit, wie ich das jetzt auch habe.
Def-Default-Interface.
Ey, das labert halt.
Das hat keine Ahnung, was das macht.
Also normalerweise ist Opus verschlauer.
In it?
Was?
In Endpoint?
What the fuck?
Was?
What?
Was macht das?
Was ist, wenn du den Reset zweimal hintereinander machst?
Das habe ich schon gemacht.
Das bringt tatsächlich nichts.
Warum?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Also ich glaube...
Wait for startup.
Okay, das ist next level.
Ich versuche gerade die Essenz aus dem zu checken, was der macht.
Also, der resettet.
Guck mal hier.
So, der holt sich den Stick.
Dann macht er das, was wir brauchen.
Dann macht er ein Reset.
So.
Dann.
Interface holen?
Was soll das bedeuten?
Ist Endpoint?
Endpoint out?
Was macht das überhaupt?
Ach so, das ist.
Ah.
das ist, weil die Handles unguldig sind.
Okay, macht Sinn. Gut, dann
machen wir das doch mal.
Dann machen wir das doch mal, was
der hier sagt. Also, wir resetten.
Dann sagen wir Def
Default Interface
Es wäre halt so nice, wenn ich ordentlich Copy-Pasten
könnte.
Ja, dann machen wir das so hier.
Und dann traint er das.
Und dann sendet er ein Reset.
Ja, das müssen wir ja dann nicht mehr hier drinnen machen.
Das macht der andere ja.
Was bin ich hier jetzt sehen?
In? Out? What?
Also das ist Go und das Chain ich so genau.
Also wir machen hier...
def, if, so, keine Ahnung.
So, das da ist jetzt was?
Naja, keine Ahnung, irgendwas.
f ist
done function und das andere ist error.
Okay, done.
Dann müssen wir sagen, die fair,
die fair done, das macht Sinn.
So, dann haben wir das Default Interface
und dann holt er sich
In-Endpoint-Out-Endpoint?
Alter, was
zum... Was ist das überhaupt?
Okay.
In-Out-Point, was? Eins, ne?
Immer.
Eins.
So, dann hier, das ist komisch.
halt nervige
Go-Error-Handling
gedönst.
Ich logge einfach immer.
Das ist doch auch egal. So, und jetzt brauchen wir
Out.
Out Endpoint.
So ganz sicher, wofür ich es brauche,
bin ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht.
So, jetzt habe ich den Kram.
Und dann sagt er Train.
Alte Nachrichten verwerfen.
Okay, das Copy-Paste ich mir einfach.
Das...
Glauben wir mal einfach mal,
dass es so passt.
Warum... Was hat sie...
Was haben die sich eigentlich bei Windows gedacht?
Dass es eine gute Idee ist,
dass das Terminal defaultmäßig...
defaultmäßig
eine Glocke hat?
Äh...
Chat?
Hab ich nicht.
Hab ich da nicht eben was reinkopiert gerade?
Main.go?
Da ist es doch.
Kann ich sagen, reload file?
Ah, da ist es doch.
Drain.
Wofür?
Okay, und wofür brauchte der jetzt?
Und wofür brauchte der jetzt den Out-Endpoint?
Ah, für den Reset zum Riten.
Okay, das können wir uns erstmal schenken.
In Endpoint.
Siehst du, Funds nicht.
Sauber.
Drain unexpected.
Drain.
Was ist unexpected?
Wie?
Was zum?
Mein Autokomplit ist kaputt.
Achso, ne.
Ich bin blöd.
So, Train. Okay.
Whatever.
Schauen wir mal.
Achso, das liegt vielleicht hier dran.
Ja, ja. Was?
Fail to get active config number of device.
Yeah.
Okay, also, halten wir mal fest.
Claude hat auch keinen plastischen Schimmer, was ich machen soll.
So, Leute, ich bin ratlos.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was wir machen sollen, dass der Scheiß ordentlich startet.
Was macht denn WaitForStartup?
Also hier, da kackt er schon ab.
Hier, Default Interface, geht nicht.
Problem an KI-Outsourcen.
Haben wir ja schon probiert, aber das hat nicht funktioniert.
Wir können jetzt irgendwie krass viel Talkens ausgeben und es über Nacht laufen lassen.
Das Problem ist, wir verstehen nicht, was hier passiert.
Wenn wir es verstanden haben, ist es wahrscheinlich ganz einfach, was wir machen müssen.
Also was bedeutet das nochmal?
Jetzt ist es wieder komplett kaputt.
Also Leute, ihr habt mir nicht zu viel versprochen.
USB-Device-Programming ist der Sack, Alter.
Kannst du nicht zweimal Interface Reset machen?
Doch, aber das bringt nichts.
Und ich verstehe nicht, warum.
Okay, jetzt haben wir es komplett kaputt gemacht.
Jetzt haben wir es wieder komplett kaputt gemacht.
Das heißt, jetzt muss ich mir den USB-Stick
ein- und abstöpseln.
Oh, jetzt geht's wieder.
Busy. Achso, unbind.
Also, Chat, ich bin dazu geneigt.
Wir machen noch ein bisschen.
Aber wir machen noch mal einen anderen Stream
und dann bauen wir das selbst.
Dann benutzen wir nicht diese komische Library hier,
wo wir nicht wissen, was wir machen,
sondern wir machen das wirklich mal selbst.
Ja, wir machen das wirklich selbst.
Okay, wisst ihr was?
Wisst ihr was?
Scheiß drauf.
Ich committe mir das mal kurz.
Git, ähm, nee, ist schon im Git-Report, oder?
Git add minus a, git commit minus a minus m, Kekkel.
So, top.
Also, ich würde sagen, wir machen das jetzt mal so.
Weil, hier blickt doch, das ist irgendwie einfach sinnloses Rumprobieren.
Wir machen das hier jetzt.
So.
Okay, wir machen das.
USB in new context, das können wir uns.
Ja, okay.
By the way.
S-Log
Fmc, komm, ich mach jetzt einfach mal so
ein bisschen klein
Okay, top
So, ähm
Wir machen das jetzt von Hand, scheiß drauf
Guck mal, Cloud hat uns doch tatsächlich
auch mal vorher schon ein bisschen was
Sinnvolles gepostet
Hier, ne, da
Ja, der hat gesagt
Das eigentliche Auslesen ist auch gar nicht so kompliziert.
Also, wir öffnen den Stick.
Machen wir.
Dann setzen wir Auto-Detach.
Ups.
Def Auto-Detach True.
Achso, Moment.
Error müssen wir auch hier handeln.
Error müssen wir hier handeln.
Error handeln.
Ich printe jetzt einfach grad neu.
Besten wurde abkackt.
Auto-Detach.
Dann.
Dann macht er hier irgendwie so komisches Zeug.
Was macht er da?
If CFG Error.
If Dev Closed, CTX Closed.
Ja, Moment.
Ich deferre ja schon den Kontext.
Also, ich kann ja hier schon sagen.
Hier, defer Dev Closed.
Kann ich ja machen.
Also, das ist schon okay.
Da brauche ich da keine komischen Ifs.
Also, jetzt mache ich hier CFG.
CFG Interface 1.
CFG Interface.
Und dann kann man schon Messages von dem N-Stick lesen.
Also das ist in Anführungsstrichen
Das ist alles
Damit wir das jetzt nicht alles einzeln tippen müssen
Damit wir das nicht alles einzeln
Tippen müssen
Machen wir jetzt hier den
Return endstick
Endstick dann
Das da brauchen wir jetzt.
Ich muss unbedingt gucken, dass ich irgendwie
mein Copy-Pasten zum Laufen bekomme.
Weil das sonst echt ziemlich
dumm ist.
Loading File System Changes.
ach so ctx ist usb ctx das brauchen wir ja alles nichts ist dass das klausen wir ja schon
die für cfg klaus da müssen wir also das ist das ist doch wirklich echt eklig oder
Das ist doch echt eklig, ey.
So.
Und jetzt siehst du den Scheiß. Gibt's ja noch nicht einmal.
Guck mal, hier nennt das
In-Out.
Ne, Moment.
Inf. Wo kommt
denn das jetzt her?
Wo kommt denn jetzt hier auf einmal Inf her?
Inf?
Au!
Das habe ich aus Versehen gelöscht.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Sekunde.
Jetzt sieht man schon, dass ich eine Weile dabei bin.
Das brauchen wir noch.
Ja.
CFG in...
In?
Ja, aber...
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Moment, warte mal. Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Aber davon abgesehen...
Das gibt's...
Mann!
Das hat sich Opus zusammen halluziniert.
Leute, es reicht mir für heute. Ich hab keinen Bock mehr.
Ich mach das gerade wieder rückgängig.
So, bam
Echt, es reicht schon
Ich kann nicht mehr denken, keine Ahnung
Also das ist echt abartig
Das ist wirklich richtig abartig
Kurz Heartbeat aus den 65
Ups, das hab ich nochmal committed
Hier ist jetzt irgendein Mist noch drin von vorhin.
Ja, dieser ganze Shit hier, das...
...komm mal nicht.
Ich meine auf der anderen Seite...
Auf der anderen Seite...
Es funktioniert ja jedes zweite Mal.
Das heißt...
Moment.
Ich hab da noch eine Idee.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich die Funktion nennen soll.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Geht das?
Ach ne, das funktioniert nicht, weil ich ja Fatal Errore.
Ich Fatal Errore ja.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Ne, ne, ne.
Kann man das catchen?
Ne, ne.
Ich müsste...
Ich müsste Errors returnen.
Anstatt Fatal.
Ja, ne, ne.
Ich müsste Errors returnen.
Aber...
Aber, aber, Leute.
Aber, ich hab ne Idee.
Oh, beste.
Leute, Five Hat.
Pass mal auf. Das ist die
Five Hat Idee schlechthin.
Run.sh
bin bash
Bam.
Äh.
Warum oder oder?
Der sollte doch eigentlich nur, wenn er abkackt...
Achso, weil ich Ctrl-C drücke.
Okay, okay.
Aber von der Idee her geht's doch schon mal.
Äh, Moment, Moment.
Sag mal...
Was für ein...
Oh ne, jetzt ist es wieder komplett broken.
For fuck's sake.
Oh nein.
Ähm.
Wenn man es Ctrl-C'et, ist es Error?
Okay, Ctrl-C ist Error 1.
Und wenn der abkackt, ist es auch Error 1.
Ja, das kann man ja überhaupt nicht unterscheiden.
Okay, Reset failed.
Ich weiß, was wir unterscheiden.
Easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy.
Noch besser.
Cap.
Reset failed.
Achso, ne, das ist ja Blödsinn jetzt.
Ähm, minus V.
Kann das jetzt mal abkacken, please?
Warum geht das jetzt auf einmal?
Das soll abkacken.
Okay, gut.
Ah, Moment.
Das ist falsch.
Weil hier...
2 nach...
und...
und 1.
Okay
Also, wenn das hier
Reset
Echo 0, okay
Das heißt, wenn das
Nicht funktioniert hat
Okay
Function, ne wie war das in Bash
Function, Run
Pseudo, Run
Grab
Grab minus V, Reset
Und jetzt kann ich sagen
Run oder oder Run
Ist das jetzt richtig
Oder bin ich
Oder ist es einfach dumm
Ich hab was falsch gemacht.
Geht das so nicht?
Kann man die Dinger so nicht chainen, oder was?
Ah, ne, man braucht das da nicht, gell?
Weil es Bash.
Was?
Grab command not found.
Wie?
Wie command not found?
Was?
Wie jetzt?
Wie kann Crab nicht gefaundet werden?
Leute, noch nicht mal einfach doppelt starten, wenn das erste abkackt, ist irgendwie einfach.
Warum faundet der Crab nicht?
Crap, was?
Hä?
Äh.
Moment, Chat.
Suche Erklärung.
War da ein Sonderzeichen?
Function run.
Ich hab leider mein...
Mein Wim macht keinen...
Ich hab hier keine Wim-Config, die...
sich die History speichert.
Geht das nicht?
Haben wir das nicht so
Jaden? Achso, doch.
Okay, wenn er abkackt, soll er es nochmal machen.
Okay,
das ist aktuell umgedreht.
Also muss ich sagen, nicht oder, oder, oder
und, und.
Okay.
Ha! Es funzt, Leute!
Pfeif het!
Es funzt.
Guck mal, wir machen jetzt einfach Run.
Und wenn das abkackt...
Das startet einfach neu.
Vielleicht sollte ich...
Vielleicht sollte ich es ein bisschen robuster
zu machen.
Also wenn das
nichts 10x Engineer
Power ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Weiß.
Skate for Donuts.
Sehr schön.
Hast du studiert oder hast du eine Ausbildung
gemacht?
Also weil
das Ding ist jetzt ja,
ganz ehrlich, ich kann jetzt eh nichts
mehr machen. 18 Uhr gehe ich futtern, 15 Minuten bleibe ich
in so einem Ort. So, wir haben es jetzt ein bisschen
unschön, würde ich sagen,
gelöst, das Problem.
Ich würde nämlich sagen,
was ich jetzt ja prinzipiell noch gerne ausprobieren würde,
ist,
das an ein Frontend zu schicken.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise, Leute.
Es in irgendeiner Art und Weise schön zu machen,
das mache ich heute bestimmt nicht mehr.
Das sage ich euch gleich.
Also hübsch wird das heute nicht mehr.
Aber wie macht man denn?
Golang Websockets.
Gorilla Websockets.
Websockets.
Komm.
Simple.
Einfaches
Govexor Example.
Mit Gorilla Websocket.
Chat.
Gibt es in der Standard-Lib?
Gibt es da nichts?
STD-Lib?
Doch, mittlerweile ja, aber mit Einschränkungen.
Okay.
Also, was braucht man hier?
Also, Gorilla Websocket.
Dann die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Ausbildungsvideos, ja, nice, nice
Okay, also wir brauchen Gorilla Websocket
So viel ist schon mal klar
Dann, äh, Upgrader
Was macht das Ding da? Warum ist das so kompliziert schon wieder?
Moment
Moment, Moment
Gorilla Websocket, wir gucken uns mal ein Exempel hier an
Ich glaube, ich glaube ChatGPT macht es wieder komplizierter
Als es sein muss
Äh
Moment, warum ist mein Browser gerade voll am eskalieren?
Nur weil es GitHub aufmacht.
Kann das sein, dass mein Rechner gerade ein bisschen am Abkacken ist?
Äh, gar nicht.
Example. Chat-Example.
Client-Server-Example. Okay.
Server-Go.
Ah, das sieht doch schon besser aus.
Also.
Wir machen im Endeffekt
Handle Function Echo, Handle Function Home.
Das ist die Webseite, das ist der Web-App,
das ist der Endpunkt,
soweit ich das sehe.
Home, ja, ja.
Echo Upgrader.
Na okay, das ist doch gar nicht so verkehrt,
was ChatGPT hier zusammengewurschtelt hat.
Ja.
So, dann müssen wir jetzt allerdings
Ich will, dass das Ding...
Ich will jetzt noch auf...
Wenigstens, dass das noch auf der Webseite angezeigt wird, okay?
So, also.
Jetzt müssen wir gucken.
Run.
Das starten wir mal in einer Go-Routine, okay?
Dann ist einfach schon mal Ruhe.
Dann endlos kreiselt das hier vor sich hin.
Okay, Go.
Go.
WS-Händler brauchen wir noch.
listening 80 80 80 80 ok ws händler sowie es händler nehmen wir das hier
ws händler
Upgrader gibt es schon mal nicht.
Geil.
Achso.
Vielleicht nehmen wir einfach das da.
Und machen es nicht so kompliziert.
Upgrader.
Warum braucht man da so einen
WS-Händler?
WS-Händler.
Prefer Close.
Es kann ein Error return.
Scheiß drauf.
Error Handling ist jetzt nicht im Scope heutzutage.
Äh, heute Abend.
Okay.
Heißt, ich starte das Ding jetzt mal.
Run.
Jetzt muss ich den ganzen Kempel noch runterladen.
Nochmal neu kompilieren.
Okay.
Find address already in use.
Ja.
Ähm.
1, 3, 3, 7.
Okay.
Auch nicht schlecht.
Okay, Listening.
Also, WS...
Wie ist das? WS...
Cat?
WS Socket? Da gab's doch so ein...
Ah, da gab's doch so ein Websocket-Tool.
Kann Curl mittlerweile Websockets?
Wie, wirklich?
Moment, kann das mittlerweile?
Websocket hieß das, nicht WS.
Ja, das suche ich.
damit konnte man websocket websocket verbindung ganz sinnvoll die banken also
hier wie wir das jetzt websocket und dann wie es doppelpunkt doppel slash
localhost 1237 404
localhost
Ah, habe ich
überhaupt gesagt, dass das ein Web
Websocket
sein soll?
Moment.
Scheiß auf Chat-GPT.
Main?
Ah, ne.
Ist doch
Ist doch okay.
Achso, ich bin ja auch blöd.
Slash WS.
Okay, Funst.
Funst, Websocket-Verbindung Funst.
Okay, jetzt ist das nächste Ding.
Wie krieg ich
Da brauch ich ein Channel, oder?
Ich brauch so ein globalen
Wie gesagt, schön wird's jetzt nicht
Wir machen einen globalen Channel
Da schreiben wir einfach nur die aktuelle Herzfrequenz rein
Ja
War
Global
Make
Ähm, ich kann die Syntax nicht
So hier
Make
Channel
Und zwar, ja letztendlich
Ints, oder?
Int
Channel aus Ints
Anbauende Channel aus Ints
Wobei, ein anbauende Channel
Ne, ein Stück reichen
Und dann soll er überschreiben, oder was soll er?
Was macht Go bei einem Channel,
wenn der voll ist?
Chat, überschreibt es dann
oder hängt an der Writer?
Okay.
Dann hängt der Writer.
So, hier haben wir die Herzfrequenz.
Herzfrequenz
BPM
Wie schreibt man das rein?
So?
BPM ist ein Typ
Byte
Na gut, dann
wird das jetzt so?
Okay, jetzt schreibt er das rein
Von der Idee her
sollte das jetzt eigentlich
funktionieren
for message read message.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Read message, vollkommen egal.
Write message interessiert uns.
So, und jetzt, wir wollen jetzt
von diesem global channel
wollen wir eine Schleife
machen.
Message.
Und dann sagen wir write message.
Und das war's.
Write.
Achso, error.
Right?
Was ist MT?
MT?
Was MT?
Wo kommt denn das her?
Ach hier, auch Read Message.
Das brauchen wir doch gar nicht.
Write Message.
Ach, Message Type.
Gibt es da irgendeinen
E-Name?
Message
Type?
Äh.
Message Types?
Text Message?
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
So, verstehe.
Und jetzt hier Message.
Ach, das geht nicht.
To.
Ah, das ist Go.
Moment, Go?
Stillconf?
Nee.
Ähm.
Oh Gott.
Go.
Int?
I-O-T-A?
Oder so?
Okay.
Go into string.
Ach, einfach string drumrum schreiben.
Okay, auch gut.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Äh.
Wie jetzt?
Wie war das nochmal?
String Conf, war ich doch richtig?
Ich war doch gar nicht so verkehrt am Anfang.
Hä?
Wir können loslegen.
Ist das kein Int?
Ist doch ein Int.
Was?
Ah!
Moment.
Das heißt, ich kann auch gar nicht.
Ich brauch da ein Byte von.
Bytes?
Oh Gott, ich mach zu selten was in Go, Alter.
Das ist schon wieder ein halbes Jahr her.
Ähm.
So?
Ne, ne, ne.
String to
Byte Buffer Go.
Auto-Sensing
to Byte Array. Ja, ja.
So?
So? Ne, oder?
Einfach so?
Ah, okay. Nice.
Ja, wenn man öfters Go macht, dann
geht es auch einfacher von der Hand.
So, jetzt sollte ich eigentlich mein
Heartbeat bekommen.
Über Websocket.
Es funzt.
Heartbeat über
Websocket.
Gut.
Diese komische Sensor-ID können wir
uns sparen. Die brauchen wir nicht.
Wozu?
Damit ist es nicht so, als hätten wir
da irgendwie mehrere.
Okay, next.
Jetzt brauchen wir eine Webseite.
Und das packen wir
in einer halben Stunde, aber dann ist es auch gut.
Ähm.
New.
HTML-File.
Index.html.
Titel.
ipo shy
check w
erstmal gucken ob er das ausliefern kann
so wir brauchen jetzt einen weiteren
endpunkt wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab
handle funct slash
ähm
index händler so irgendwie so
index händler
so
Wie?
Von der Idee her, ne?
Hier, warte mal, jetzt müssen wir hin als Index.
Von der Idee her ist es doch easy.
Ich sag jetzt write und da rein jetzt quasi file.
Ne, wie war das?
Moment, Moment.
Go, I-O, Punkt.
Read.
Read all.
Ne, das auch nicht.
Ich mach zu selten was in Go.
Oder was?
Doch, file.
Go return texts.
Okay, nee.
Go read texts.
Okay, man kann es auch kompliziert machen.
Buff I own new reader.
Moment, warte mal, warte mal.
Go
Surf Index HTML
from current start.
Ja.
Was?
Golang.
Hä?
Was? Was ist das?
Go, Run, EOF,
Def 0, hä?
Was?
Chat, geh mit dir.
Was machst du da?
Ach, das geht?
Ach ja.
tatsächlich
das geht, das wusste ich gar nicht
das ist ja nice, man muss das
gar nicht selbst handeln
es gibt nen
Handelfiles, Handelfiles, aber dir
ok, das ist cool
run
das heißt, wenn ich jetzt sage
curl
Dann krieg ich mein Index HTML
So
Und jetzt müssen wir Websocket machen da drinnen
Welcher von euch
High IQ Chatgis
Kann Websocket aus dem Kopf
Das war nicht schwer
Aber wie gesagt ich mach das zu selten
Also es ist auf jeden Fall
Irgendwas in der Richtung hier
Script
war WS gleich
Websocket?
Genau.
Oder war es New Websocket?
Ich glaube es war New Websocket.
Websocket
URL
Localhost
Port 1234
Siehst du?
Konst ist besser, ihr habt recht.
Bei reis ist super krass am lecken gerade mein editor guckt euch das mal kommt jetzt voll abkacken kann
Das ist das voller mescal
Was genau passiert hier gerade
Hey warum bricht es nicht ab
chat
Warum bricht das nicht ab?
Kill all?
Wie habe ich das genannt?
Run.sh?
Okay, bam.
Ich mache jetzt einfach so.
Was?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Der hängt noch.
Netzte...
Die Probleme hast du mit Go aber doch
wirklich selten.
Port 1, 2, 3.
Okay, sudo.
Go-App.
Kill all Go-App.
Was?
Okay.
Bam!
Oh, ich raste aus.
Ich dreh durch.
Okay.
Okay, gut.
Abbrechen.
Sag mal, wie...
Okay, doch, jetzt geht's.
Ich hau jetzt einfach so auf Ctrl-C rein.
Okay, das hat mein Skript irgendwie gefressen vorher.
Keine Ahnung.
So, wir gucken jetzt mal weiter.
Also, jetzt haben wir WebSocket am Start.
So.
Jetzt geht's WS.
Äh, Message oder irgendwie sowas?
On Message?
Message?
Sag mir, wenn ich Mist mache.
Log?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, warte mal.
Console.
Console Log, ne?
Log.
Console Log.
Message.
So, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob das so im Prinzip funktioniert.
Äh.
Message?
Event?
Wie ging das nochmal?
Ging das so?
Message Event.
WS on Message.
On Message.
Ah.
So, ne?
Message.
So ist richtig, gell?
Ja, ja, genau.
Wenn man das jeden Tag macht, hat man das nicht so im Kopf.
So.
Message.
Data.
Kann Anything sein.
console log data ok schau mal starten
ja ja no dwarf 5 ok alles alles klar sage ich auch immer
Was? Cannot connect?
Warum nicht?
Ah, es sind nicht 1, 2, 3, 4.
Ich kack nur. Es ist 1, 2, 3, 7.
Lul.
Sag mal, was genau geht hier eigentlich gerade im Hintergrund ab,
wenn ich die App beende?
Kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Was, was, was?
Was geht hier gerade?
Was ist hier los?
Was ist an der App so highly complex?
Was ist hier so schlimm dran?
Also vor allem, warum beendet der sich nicht?
Ah.
Könnte das hier das Problem sein,
weil das hier eine Endlosschleife ist?
Und die nicht gebraked wird?
Also brauche ich da...
Brauche ich da auch sowas wie das hier?
Aber die...
Also ich verstehe das Problem ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum das jetzt hängt.
Okay.
Ey, pass auf. Ein klassisches
Go-Problem, sagt ChatGPTL.
Ein klassisches
Go-Problem.
Oh, Leute, ich glaube, das klassische Go-Problem ist
mir geht der RAM aus.
Das ist, glaube ich, das klassische Go-Problem.
Das klassische
Go-Problem ist gar nicht so, gar nicht so klassisch.
Ich glaube, mir ging einfach nur der RAM aus.
Excellent.
Okay, kill.
Netstat.
Ich weiß nicht, warum es hängt, ehrlich gesagt.
Keine Ahnung.
Kill minus 9. Bam.
Ich hoffe jetzt, nachdem mein RAM wieder am Start ist, geht das.
Firefox cannot establish connection to.
Warum?
Warum nicht?
Geht doch hier auch.
Warum? Warum nicht?
Wo ist das Problem?
Firefox?
Du hast WS vergessen?
Wo?
Ah, Slash WS habe ich vergessen.
Du hast recht. Slash WS.
Okay, gut. Excellent.
Chat, GG.
Ich freue mich, dass ihr aufpasst.
Okay, das sind meine Herzfrequenzwerte.
Excellent, excellent.
Kann mir einer erklären, warum das so langsam ist?
Warum das nicht schneller reinkommt?
Warum kommt das nicht schneller rein?
Ah, okay, doch.
Doch, doch, das kommt schneller rein.
Das ist bloß immer der gleiche Wert.
Okay, gut.
Also, das hätten wir.
Das heißt, es bleibt uns jetzt eigentlich nur noch eine Sache übrig.
Diff.
Hard Rate.
Null.
Wir machen, komm.
Äh, äh, Hard.
Hat KDE nicht so einen Emoji Picker?
Emoji?
Emoji Selector.
Hard.
Okay, brauchen wir irgendwas Schönes.
Das da.
Heartrate.
Machen wir so.
ID, gleich.
Beste.
So, jetzt kommen krasse CSS-Skills, beziehungsweise JavaScript-Skills.
Pass auf.
Document.
Get element by ID.
Beste.
Und jetzt inner.
Das mache ich inner Text, ne?
Inner Text gleich.
Moment, wir brauchen Template Strings.
Template Strings.
Zack.
Äh, so.
So.
Message Data.
Pass mal auf.
Magic.
Die Magie passiert jetzt.
Seht ihr das?
Es funzt.
Ich habe meine Heartrate im Browser.
Auf eine maximal hässliche Art und Weise mit Go.
Einfach halb tot mit 59?
Also normalerweise habe ich abends so einen Puls von 53, 54.
Du hast 47.
Oh, da bist du aber auch viel am Sport machen.
47 ist schon wirklich
sehr weit unten.
Das heißt, du hast ein...
Wie sagt man?
Nicht großes Herz.
Du hast ein...
Also du pumpst viel mit einmal Herzschlag.
Ich gehe quasi jeden Tag joggen
zwischen 6 und 15 Kilometer.
das je nachdem was der trainingsplan sagt gestern habe ich pause gemacht 39 rupels ist
krass ich habe man ich habe ein interview mit mit mit jan ulrich gesehen und er hat gesagt
er hatte den ruhepuls also zu zeiten wo er tolle france gefahren ist hatten ruhepuls von 38
und und was ich auch super krass fand ich weiß ich weiß nicht ob ihr marco pantani kennt das
Das war auch ein Radfahrer, ein Radprofi zu Zeiten, wo der Jan Ulrich gefahren ist.
Und der war ja wirklich bis zu den Oberkante, Unterlippe gedoped mit Epo und allem möglichen Zeug.
Der ist später auch an Drogenmissbrauch gestorben.
Nicht wegen Doping, aber wegen anderen Substanzen.
Der war komplett voll.
So, um das zu erklären.
Epo sorgt dafür, dass du mehr rote Blutkörperchen hast.
Das heißt, wenn du mehr rote Blutkörperchen hast, kann dein Blut mehr Sauerstoff transportieren,
was natürlich sehr nice ist für Leistungssportler, logischerweise.
Aber das ist ja nicht umsonst verboten.
Das Problem ist, der Kerl hatte so viele rote Blutkörperchen.
Also der Nachteil von so vielen roten Blutkörperchen ist natürlich, dass es irgendwann verstopfen kann.
Und der hat mal in einem Interview erzählt, in seinen Hochzeiten, wo er sich da voll gedopt hat mit Epo ohne Ende,
der musste, der hatte nachts
einen
Alarm
wenn sein Puls unter
keine Ahnung, 35 gegangen ist
ich sag jetzt mal eine Zahl, ich weiß es nicht
unter 35, unter 40, ich weiß es nicht
also wenn sein Puls unter ein gewisses Level gegangen ist
dann hat ihn der Alarm nachts
aufgeweckt
und er musste dann aufstehen
und rumlaufen, weil sonst
sein Herzinfarkt und Schlaganfallrisiko
zu hoch wäre
Weil das sonst verstopft wäre
Also man kann sich
Man kann sich
Man kann sich tot dopen
Das ist möglich, ja
Die Probleme haben wir natürlich
Mit Leuten, die einfach nur trainieren
Ohne Doping zu nehmen
Haben wir das nicht
Wir haben halt auch nicht
Diesen krassen
Roten Blutkörperchen kauend, ja
Das ist schon
Das ist schon heftig, oder?
Chat, wir machen eine Sache noch
Eine Sache noch
Guck mal, man kann doch jetzt richtig coole Animationen machen
Mit CSS, oder?
Wir fragen jetzt
Ich will keine Talkings verbraten bei mir hier
Wir fragen jetzt ChatGPT
Ja
Wir sagen
Ich
Hallo
Ich würde gerne eine Beat-Animation
mit CSS machen bei
jeder Aktualisierung.
Mal gucken,
ob das Chat-Gipfel...
Klar, du kannst beim Einrevel einfach eine
CSS-Animation auf dein bestes Element setzen.
Zum Beispiel
ein kleiner Heartbeat-Pulse-Effekt.
Obviously.
Ein kleiner Heartbeat-Pulse-Effekt.
Wo muss denn das rein?
In head, oder was?
Wo muss das rein hier?
In style? In head.
Hedda, Alter.
Und jetzt?
Ah, guck mal hier.
Chat-GPT ist ja wieder...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das alles braucht, aber...
Beste Punkt...
Nee, beste...
Beste hier.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee, Beste hier oben zu setzen.
Kann man nämlich einfach sagen, Beste in der Text.
So, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal, ob ChatGPT recht hat und das jetzt gut aussieht.
Das Pulsieren ist abhängig von der Herzfrequenz, weil es bei jedem Update pulsiert.
Wir schauen mal, ob ChatGPT was Sinnvolles gebaut hat.
Ähm...
Nun ja.
Vielleicht nicht ganz so geil.
Na gut, es updatet bei jeder Nachricht.
Das heißt ja nicht...
Okay, wir müssen noch was einbauen.
Wir müssen noch was einbauen.
Wir müssen sagen, if...
If...
Aber hier
Konst value
If value
If value ungleich, ach so
current value brauchen wir noch
Was weiß ich current value
Current value if man kommt hier new value also wenn
das ungleich ist
Nur wenn das ungleich ist,
dann machen wir diesen ganzen
Krempel hier, okay? Oder sagen wir mal so,
wenn das gleich ist,
sagen wir einfach
Return.
Was hat er denn hier jetzt für Scherzen dran?
Achso, weil das
kein Int ist. Ja gut, dann
Bam Bam.
Oder auch nicht? Es ist JavaScript, es wird schon klappen.
Oh.
Ups.
Okay, es funzt nicht.
Oh, ich update die Current Value ja auch gar nicht.
Okay, ist Funst.
Es schlägt nur beim Updaten.
Aber das ist ja auch nicht richtig, ne?
Das ist ja auch nicht richtig, wenn das nur beim Updaten schlägt.
Das sieht jetzt aus, als hätte ich jetzt Rhythmusstörung.
Wir müssen das selbst berechnen.
Das kannst du nicht anhand der Events machen.
Wir müssen eine Frequenz berechnen.
Das ist das Einzige, was wir machen können.
Also wir müssen die Geschwindigkeit selbst berechnen.
Aber das ist mir jetzt tatsächlich zu aufwendig,
weil da müssten wir diesen Kram hier im Hintergrund irgendwie laufen lassen.
Also, das Ding ist, wir müssten das selbst berechnen.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ziemlich, ziemlich peger.
Wir können ja, wir können ja Chat kommen, wir prompten Chat-GPT.
Lass das Herz nur so schnell pulsieren, wie die Frequenz ist.
ok also ok ok was was sagt die dauer aus der zeit zwischen zwei websocket
updates berechnen was ein du sollst es so schnell schlagen lassen wie der puls
in message punkt data
Ah, verstanden.
Okay.
Können wir...
Trauen wir Chat-GPT komplett?
Bam.
Schauen wir mal, ob das sinnvoll ist,
was es da gebaut hat.
Nice.
Einfach mit Request-Animation-Frame, okay.
Äh, nein, ChatGPT
Nein, nein
Nein
Cannot resolve, okay
Sehr gut
ChatGPT, das war
Nicht so nice, würde ich sagen
Komm, wir geben jetzt mal Cloud Code
Die Chance, das zu machen
Okay, okay, ich hab
eine Idee.
Als Ding kam, kommen wir erstmal wieder weg.
Das machen wir jetzt erstmal mal wieder weg hier, okay?
Weg. Weg.
Weg.
Ich mach den Kram mal weg hier.
Scheiß drauf.
und jetzt das jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt prompt wird es prompt wenn man cloud code und gucken
beziehungsweise ich glaube opus jetzt mal opus und sagen er macht mir meine animation
da muss ich dann muss ich halt hier wieder powershell dann muss ich halt hier das ding
wieder mich jetzt connecten, weil ich halt nicht
gescheit copy-pasten kann.
Äh, Repos,
Pi, CLI, Champ,
Go,
App,
Index,
HTML.
Oh, nee.
Oh, Chat, ich hab mich vorhin ausgelockt.
Ich bin überhaupt nicht mehr eingelockt.
Fuck.
Ich hab mich ausgelockt bei, bei,
Meinem KI-Kram
Weil ich den Stream ausmachen wollte vorher
Okay, dann
Lass uns doch Chat-GPT retten
Wir müssen ihm genau sagen, was wir wollen
Ich will eine
Beat-Animation
Für das Herz
In
In Message.Data
Steht die aktuelle
Puls-Requence
Ich will, dass
das Herz so schnell
pulsiert, wie der
Puls aktuell
gerade ist.
Okay, ja dann.
Okay, Chat-GPT ist,
glaube ich, tatsächlich
zu dumm dafür.
Weil
das macht wieder den gleichen Fehler.
Genau, ich kann die China-Chinesen-AI noch fragen.
Guck mal mal, was die sagt.
Es checkt mit dem,
der macht wieder den gleichen
Klang.
Es pulst
nun aber dumm
Bei jedem WS-Message.
Okay, Chat, Chat.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, was das Problem ist.
Ich weiß, was das Problem ist.
Ey, ich will nur noch mal gucken, ob Chat-GP das checkt, ja?
Set Timeout?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich...
Genau, die Animation muss unabhängig vom Message-Update sein.
Was geupdatet werden muss, ist die Frequenz von der Animation.
Irgendjemand hat gesagt, das kann man super easy mit Request Animation Frame machen.
Request Animation Frame.
Was macht das?
Wir fragen jetzt mal die Shima KI.
Oh, die China...
Komm.
Skip.
Skip now.
China KI.
DLM 4.7, Alter.
Das alles andere ist nicht...
Können wir das vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen schöner kopieren?
Die Animation muss unabhängig laufen von WS...
Von WS...
von
euer PS-Message.
YouTube Primo
is getting another price. Sag mal,
wie viel soll ich für den ganzen Miss noch
bezahlen?
Okay, hier haben wir jetzt die
Heartbeat-Animation.
Chat,
ihr krassen CSS-Kenner.
Wie...
Wie update ich...
Wie mache ich eine Endlos-Animation?
Und da muss ich ja die Frequenz da drinnen
Okay, das ist komplizierter als ich gedacht hätte
Okay, jetzt kommt
High IQ China-Chinesen-KI
Mal gucken, ob das besser ist
Okay, das klingt doch sinnvoll
Das klingt doch sinnvoll, was das hier geschrieben hat, oder?
Wollen wir mal ausprobieren, ob das stimmt?
Ich weiß, dass das alt ist.
Das Ding ist, ich habe mich gerade ausgelockt bei meinem KI-Krempel.
Und ich habe das in einem anonymen Tab offen gehabt.
Also ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr einholen.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles mitgenommen?
Ox Alpha mal getestet.
Nee.
Kann man das kostenlos verwenden?
Okay.
Die China-Chinesen-KI macht das schon mal besser.
Aber update ist es denn jetzt auch?
Okay, Chat, wir müssen jetzt mal testen.
Ich muss mich jetzt ein bisschen bewegen, okay?
Bewegungsstelz.
Moment, Gummi von der Hose ordentlich festmachen,
dass mir die Hose nicht rutscht.
Ihr müsst mir sagen, ob das jetzt auch wirklich schneller geht, ne?
Ich renne ein bisschen auf der Stelle, okay?
Wird das schneller?
Aber die Animation
sparkt immer noch ein bisschen rum, oder?
Ich glaube, viel mehr kriege ich nicht hin, wenn ich auch im Stand renne.
Tätke?
Tätke, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Ich setze mich auf Fahrrad.
Ich habe doch hier meinen Indoor-Trainer stehen.
Probieren wir nochmal aus. Sekunde.
Ich hab den jetzt nicht an.
Das heißt, ich kann nur treten ohne
Widerstand. Ich schalte jetzt einfach
auf den kleinsten Gang. Dann hat man ein bisschen Widerstand.
Und fahr mal eine Runde.
Ich hab auch keine Schuhe an
und nix.
Äh.
So.
Auf geht's.
ist zu wenig widerstand man hat überhaupt keine power überhaupt keine power das ist
keine ahnung 8 watt oder sogar ganz vergessen
80 Watt und 130 Umdrehungen die Minute oder sowas
Okay, ich gebe jetzt einmal voll Gas nochmal
So, schneller geht nicht
Okay
Aber es wird schneller, oder?
Moment, misst du deinen Puls?
Mit einer Garmin-Uhr
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall ein Unterschied.
Ja, macht auf jeden Fall einen Unterschied.
Naja gut, ich mein,
für mal schnell hingewurschtelt,
ist das schon ganz in Ordnung.
Was meintet ihr, soll ich noch für ein Model ausprobieren?
Chat, ihr meint doch, ihr habt doch eben noch was.
Das ist Ox Alpha.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Ox Alpha.
Es ist ein Stealth Model.
Was soll denn das bedeuten?
Das soll bedeuten, dass man nicht weiß, wer dahinter steckt, was dahinter steckt.
Und was mit den Daten passiert, oder?
Okay, es
thinkt.
Okay, ist das jetzt besser?
Chat, meint ihr, das ist besser?
Du hast das gemacht
Na gut, dass du dich zu erkennen gibst
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt
Schauen wir mal, ob das besser ist jetzt
Ähm
Hallo
Heartbeat
Es gibt einfach...
Das sieht ja mega
beschissen aus.
Ich finde das an sich nicht verkehrt.
Aber die Animation ist etwas...
Nun ja.
Also das ist dumm.
Da war das hier besser.
Also das war auf jeden Fall besser.
wenn auch die Animation ein bisschen
hakelig ist, ja.
Aber das sieht
wenigstens nicht so krass nachher als Rhythmusstörung aus.
Wir könnten jetzt da noch sagen,
Diff,
wir machen jetzt hier mal irgendwie Style,
komm, scheiß auf Inline,
Font,
Font-Size? Oder wie macht man das?
Ne.
Font?
Ist es nicht Font-Size?
Doch.
Keine Ahnung.
48 Pixel oder keine Ahnung.
2 EM.
Ist das so?
Hier.
Bam.
100%
Das könnte vielleicht ein bisschen
Kann man da 100%
davon
Das geht nicht
Wir könnten, wir müssten
Dings machen
Wie heißt das?
Flexbox
Dass es 100% einnimmt
Und standardmäßig sich so
seist
Aber im Prinzip, Chad, ist das doch jetzt schon mal gar nicht so schlecht, oder?
Es ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt so schön wie der hier
Also der ist schon ein bisschen hübscher
Aber ich finde das gar nicht schlecht
Ne, Sound nicht, Sound nicht
Das soll ja im Hintergrund laufen
Im Stream Overlay
Ah die Animation
Spackt ein bisschen das kriegen wir aber noch hin
Aber insgesamt ist das doch echt nicht verkehrt
Es ist glaube ich
mit das Hässlichste, was ich je
programmiert habe.
Also das hier.
Naja, gut,
nee, das stimmt nicht. Aber es ist schon...
Also, ich verstehe halt null, wie es funktioniert.
Und warum ich
ein Reset brauche,
weiß ich auch nicht.
Max macht der Active Pulling
oder Websocket.
Der macht Websocket.
Er doch in C++ ist es selbstverständlich hässlicher.
Musik
Ich bin nicht eingeschlafen.
Ich habe nur überlegt, ob wir noch was machen.
Oder ob ich jetzt esse.
Ich glaube, ich esse jetzt was.
Es reicht für heute.
Guck mal, 5 Stunden 22 an diesem dummen Problem, Alter.
Video schauen und essen.
Ne, ich muss mich jetzt eine Stunde nochmal ausruhen.
Fünfeinhalb Stunden.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es manche Leute schaffen.
Es gibt ja Leute, die streamen irgendwie jeden Tag
acht Stunden plus.
Es ist mir unbegreiflich, wie das
geht.
Mit dem Kopf acht Stunden
bei der Sache zu sein.
Und das jeden Tag.
Keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Es ist übrigens gerade kaputt.
Oh, es ist wieder kaputt, Leute.
Okay, wir werden das Problem fixen.
Und wisst ihr wie?
Power of Bam!
Ja, das ist doch schön, Elfprogrammer.
Also, dass das dir geholfen hat.
Nicht, dass das so war.
Die machen auch meistens nicht, wo sie selber viel denken müssen.
Das stimmt auch wieder.
Wir haben ja noch viel KI für uns denken lassen.
Es war auch ein Thema, wo es nichts zu gab.
Eigentlich bin ich froh, dass es geklappt hat.
Da steht jetzt ja unserem C++-Stream mit Heartbeat-Sensor nichts mehr im Wege, oder?
Du nutzt C++ in deiner Bachelorarbeit.
Warum machst du denn sowas?
Weil die Libraries, die ich vergleiche, in C++ geschrieben sind.
Oh shit.
Was vergleichst du denn für Libraries?
Das ist bestimmt irgendwelches wissenschaftliches Zeug, oder?
das sagt mir was das ist glaube ich eine gui cute rapper für pein kann das sein
task basierte runtimes ich habe keine ahnung was das überhaupt bedeuten soll
A distributed...
Alter, krass, eine Library mit 23 Sternen.
Ähm, ist es nicht vielleicht ein bisschen unsupported?
Distributed multi-threading runtime for global view fork joint task parallelism.
What?
Gut, Fivehead, du machst das schon.
Und was ist das andere?
Legion.
Legion CPP.
Ne, TBL.
Basic Turn-Based Strategy Game.
Ne, das ist was anderes.
Hier, Legion Parallel Programming System.
Okay, das würde ich auf jeden Fall der Sache vorziehen.
Weil das ist Active Maintained.
Und, naja, mehr oder weniger.
Und es hat ein paar Sterne mehr.
Echt, da war noch...
Ach, die nutzen nur nicht GitHub.
Okay.
Okay, verstehe.
Gut, Chat.
Schön, dass ihr alle dabei wart heute.
Auch wenn so ein wirklich hardcore Bastel...
rumgefrickelt Stream war.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat,
freut mich trotzdem.
Wer noch nicht gefollowt hat, ihr wisst, ich freue mich auch über jeden Follow, muss ja nicht immer ein Subscription sein, weil grüne Pfeile, die nach oben zeigen, sind beste.
Chat, was ist das? Was ist das hier? Mich haben sechs Leute unsubscribed während dem Stream heute.
Aber es haben auch welche gefollowed.
Drei Stück haben gefollowed.
Oh, ich sechste euch
unsubscribed. Was ist da los?
Die haben das Elend mit
N-Plus nicht ertragen, oder was?
Ah, ja, ja.
Ja, dann muss jetzt nochmal hart rein
gefollowed werden, wer noch nicht hat.
Gut.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, Leute.
Ich hau jetzt ab.
Bis denn. Macht's gut.
See you.